okay for the those in the audience this
the online signin sheet is closed at
8:00 on the morning of the hearing if
you haven't signed in then uh you people
will be asked at the end of the hearing
if they wish to testify and raise your
hand be
recognized have we started the
recording I don't know M
Marling yes it's started all right we
are recorded we are
live as chair of the house Edna
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule
67 and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pent to executive order
20204 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
hearing on bills referred to the
committee and scheduled in the house
calendar for today an executive session
may be held on any Bill referred to the
committee please note there's no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order I am confirming that all
members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to listen and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting complies with house rules n
RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271 3600 or email HCS leg. state. n.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and resed all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote we'll start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each
[Music]
memb please
also
trying to
un when you state your presence please
also State whether there's anyone in the
room with you during this meeting which
is required under the right to no law
representative scitech R when
you're
representative algro is here
representative Bailey is here
representative
fellows present Home
Alone representative
funno representative
funno not present yet representative
goalie here at home and my wife is in
the other
room representative
groa here in my office
Al representative
Judy uh representative
Lara here I am home a full house with
everybody on Zoom for Nashville
School representative leus is here
representative McGuire is here
representative
O'Brien representative O'Brien yes I am
president I am home alone in
nsha representative
Pearson I'm here and Barry at home my
wife's
upstairs representative Roy I'm here
home
along represent representative Santo
naso
representative Santo
naso okay not yet I guess representative
Schmidt I am preson at my home office in
Dover I am alone representative sh I am
present at my home in pemro alone
representative
Schultz I believe she had a bill to
introduce okay uh the CL is
here representative
yakovich is
here uh and he'll sign at some point
okay and uh representative funno have
you showed
up not yet representative Santo
naso not yet we keep our eyes we will
indeed opening the public
hearing I call uh representative
Huff Madam CH you're cutting out sorry
I'm I need to be uh more stationary
we're open the public hearing
representative Huff hello can you hear
me yes okay uh thank you madam chair and
members of the committee my name is Greg
Huff I am a representative belnap County
District 3
Laconia I am introducing HB 275 of which
I'm a co-sponsor an act relative to the
governor's power to initiate a state of
emergency and various emergency
Powers this bill revises the governor's
Emergency Management powers in RSA
445 and requires the legislature or
executive Council to renew a state of
emergency when 445
was penned the last year of this covid
uh 19 state of emergency could not have
been imagined and as such its
problematic real world shortfalls became
apparent
445 was never put forth to circumvent
our constitutional government and the
branches of checks and balances yet
inadvertently it has HB 275 is set to
remedy those issues in section one
a condition that must be specified is
added under
e the condition necessary to extend the
state of emergency this is to provide a
clear reason to extend a state of
emergency and eliminate the current
arbitrary sub subjective
reasons in section two a b and
c those restructure the intent to use
the branches of government and not just
the executive Branch this would involve
both houses of the legislature and
provide a safety in the event that the
full bodies of the House and Senate were
unable to convene by allowing the
executive Council to address the
continuance of a state of
emergency D in this section is provided
as an incentive or a deterrent uh to use
that safety as a last
resort um HB 275 also includes clud a
very important section uh
2G this can create a nominal state of
emergency kind of a uh state of
emergency uh light if you will one of
the big attractions to keeping a state
of emergency going is to allow the flow
of federal funding to come in that can
help our state this would keep that door
open while not allowing for the
extending of powers to any
officials
section three will make it clear and
it's expressly written quote within the
limits of the governor's constitutional
and statutory Authority end quote the
Constitution cannot be usurped and the
governor alone cannot create nor suspend
law and finally in section 3D is a
safeguard against abuse of power by any
uh public officer such that removal from
office is
possible uh thank you madam chair and
members of the committee that's uh 275
in its basic
form point of order Madam chair yes
representative Schmidt thank you is it
appropriate for representative Huff to
be testifying uh without having his
camera on so that we can see
him yes we have had members of the
committee speak without without video
but we
you only need it to vote however it is
more polite of him to turn his video on
so he can actually see him it's more
effective so I hope he will do so I've
done so M there he
goes handsome
dude have you completed representative h
i I am thank you very much for your
testimony is there any questions from
the
committee I have a question Madam chair
yes representative leus got there first
that's fine just a technical question on
page one line
24 it um it talks about a super majority
vote of both Chambers the question is is
a super major is the word super majority
defined anywhere either in the
Constitution or Stat because U you know
there are different super majorities you
know voting it's a legisl
some things are 23 some things are 3s
some are
just uh thank you representative for
your question I am not aware of that
particular
um uh section typically uh I will say I
I'm of the assumption that it would be a
two-thirds but I had not noticed a
specific to
that representative
schm thank you madam
chair just make sure I'm both on audio
and video uh the question I have for
representative Huff is the structure F
first of all is this a bill of your own
devising because it it it it has a
number of aspects uh that are troubling
and I'm wondering whether you're in a
position to I know um make changes to
accommodate the committee's objections
uh thank you representative um I'm a
co-sponsor but I am uh third and batting
order uh simply just to introduce the
bill there are other uh Representatives
who are far more vested into this and
probably could answer questions a lot uh
more in depth than I can um I'd be more
than happy to to to give you what I know
of it I I I do know um a decent amount
but there will be uh folks coming in to
this discussion they I had to introduce
other legislation so um I I would defer
to them if if I can't uh answer you
thank you thank you
madam followup no representative Schmidt
he says he did not the best person to
answer and other people are coming in so
we'll defer the question as well if you
don't mind no that's
okay representative saitech uh question
of the chair representative Schmidt
asked whether he's in a position to do
anything with the bill the fact is the
bill is in our possession at this point
he doesn't really have anything to do
with it
correct the uh but I suspect we're going
to be making some amendments to this
bill representative and that's why
there's a work schedule work session
scheduled for immediately after the
hearings so that we can get your input
as well as others on the committee thank
you I'm aware of that but I appreciate
that all right
um yes oh perhaps the others are
listening but I have a problem uh with
this nominal state of emergency and I'd
like to get that ball into play and
that's it's either a state of emergency
or it's not if this is a subterfuge to
get federal funds without it being a
real emergency uh I'm not comfortable
with that position I don't know that it
may be legal it may be but I'm just not
comfortable with I believe that
representative Pearson has some data on
that the difference between a fire
that's burning and a fire that is
controlled it's still a fire but you
treat it differently so we I've made my
I've made my point I don't like the idea
of that section either so we will uh
we'll definitely be discussing that well
that's enough instruction for very good
um let's see
is all right I call just in case
thank you representative off for your
testimony thank you madam chair and
thank you members of the committee
representative gr you asking a question
well I had my raised my hand raised I'm
sorry I don't think you saw it I'm sorry
I have a new staff person here he's not
up on it sorry I'm just mad Madame chair
representative Pearson I I have a
technical problem that I I need someone
to address if that's okay yes it's a
it's a zoom problem can can Pam or
somebody there I need the link sent to
my other email address because I'm I've
forwarded 20 minutes ago off my
legislative email and it's stuck in
limbo and it won't
forward so there someone
there take care of that I heard that and
if I have your other address which I'm
sure I do it's Pearson Forda F Pearson
forer
gmail.com okay great I'll do that in
right now thank
you okay representative O'Brien you had
a
question yes I do Madam chair thank you
so much um I I wonder if you can answer
representative uh Hulk thank you for
taking my question but on page two line3
and we're talking about section c and
you did change it from uh
evacuations and the original bill says
compel and you changed it to recommend
now my interpretation of recommend is
that if the chemical plant
exploded we suggest that you uh get out
of there and seek shelter but does this
remove and perhaps even jeopardize our
First Responders because where the a
recommendation and my interpretation of
a
recommendation would be they may choose
to stay there thus when they do get in
trouble
and it gets past the time of a safe
evacuation First Responders may have to
go back at Great
risk and to get them to leave so should
it uh what made you think of going and
eliminating the compel to go to a
recommendation uh thank you for the
question representative O'Brien
um that was not necessarily a section
that I uh I penned however ever um
further on from recommend and and I
agree with your assessment um it would
be recommend it would not be to compel
uh further on down it says any person
who does not evacuate such an area upon
the recommendation of the governor shall
not receive any additional accommodation
or Aid at the expense of the state so
literally it is up to the individual if
they uh if they decide that it's a good
idea to get out they can use uh the the
uh the offers of the the state for help
um if they decide that they uh would be
better off on their
own and they're on
their I I follow up Madam chair follow
up thank you and yes representative I
did receive that section and I
understand what you're what you're
saying there they would not receive any
uh additional accommodations or at the
aid of the state but my question is
directly the difference between a
recommendation and the compel also takes
into account
and if you could focus on it the F the
lives of the First
Responders that are evacuating the
situation
um the best I can I can do for you uh Mr
representative is is a hypothetical and
hypothetically
you I would think that a first responder
would be in more Danger trying to drag
somebody out of their home as opposed to
just having them come willingly
other than that it would all be in a
theoretical State all this does is give
uh a person uh the ability to use their
own good judgment as opposed to being
forced by the government that's all
thank you representative thank you madam
chair thank thank you for the has a
question it's not a question but U I
can't speak for the sponsors but I may
able clear up that
question um I think hold get back I'm
sure we'll be getting back to
it still had a question I think who else
had a question representative gr oh we G
I um I will um not ask my question I'll
just the work session thank you I'm
sorry R gr I didn't hear that you
weren't loud enough I'm sorry I uh
removed my question oh excellent
representative Shu you had a
question madam
chair uh following through on the line
of question that representative O'Brien
put forward I would ask um
representative Huff if he's aware that
in h a major evacuation situation you're
going to have many First Responders on
the
scene um it's likely that whoever would
have approached a person telling them
that they need to evacuate and learning
that a person is resistant to that there
would likely be other First Responders
who would not get that mess that's not
something that I believe would
ordinarily go out over their uh normal
lines of communication look out uh the
house third from the right uh they're
not going to evacuate I don't see that
happening um how can you expect that
you're not putting a certain number of
those responders in danger because
they're going to go back and attempt to
still
rescue uh I believe that's a question
that can't be answered so uh I think we
will add we've already said we're going
to be discussing this among the
committee I don't believe representative
Huff has a definitive answer for this
one all right I just wondered if they
had thought about that I think the
question is is that it will depend a
great deal on what type of an emergency
it is whether it's a fire or a flood or
a winter
storm those are the much those are the
most common forms of emergency in New
Hampshire
correct
okay
other okay other no questions uh that
case I will recall Mr Justin katees from
uh
Nashville good morning thank you very
much for the opport opportunity to
testify my name is Justin Kates I'm the
director of Emergency Management for the
city of nashille I've been in this
position for the last decade and I I'd
like to just provide some of my concerns
about how House Bill
275 uh will impact the city's ability to
respond and recover from disasters
there's two primary issues that we have
uh with the language of this bill the
first one being uh the additional
stipulations that have been added to RSA
445 uh for the state of emergency
declarations uh and how they're renewed
uh the legislative process is often slow
and deliberate to provide policy makers
with an opportunity to engage with a a
wide variety of stakeholders and fully
assess the short-term and long-term
considerations conversely Disaster
Response must be Swift and thorough to
save lives and deal with the rapidly
changing Dynamics and complexity
increasingly prevalent in these types of
disasters being experien today uh so any
legislative action that impedes the
state's ability to respond quickly and
comprehensively is really of great
concern to the Emergency Management
Community um I think another concern
there with the changes to 445 uh related
to extensions in this nominal state of
emergency uh really concern around any
gaps that might occur between the
initial emergency declaration and the
extension approval by either the general
court or the executive
Council um FEMA has taken a a kind of a
significant position I in the last uh
few years to really downshift uh more
cost to State and local government and
try and reduce its role in disaster
recovery and I see concerns about how
FEMA would interpret uh this nominal
state of emergency as a legitimate state
of emergency uh the nominal state of
emergency is not likely to be seen as
legitimate if its only purpose is really
for eligibility for disaster cost
recovery programs uh this can add
additional justification to Fe that its
programs are not necessary Beyond simply
providing financial assistance to State
and local
governments uh similarly the absence of
a state of emergency declaration if it's
been discontinued due to the lack of
renewal uh during a long-term disaster
uh certainly could send a signal to the
federal government that the event has
been handled and does not warrant a
federal
declaration um I think overall in that
first component of this uh Bill disaster
recovery programs are complex in nature
and require emergency Management's
collaboration and coordination with many
diverse interests within the community
legislative oversight of Disaster
Recovery is exceedingly helpful when
Solutions can be crafted that address
red tape and other obstacles to other
expeditious community and economic
recovery the the second primary concern
uh is to the evacuation language that's
been added in
445 uh it does not reflect the realities
of challenges encountered in disasters
requiring the evacuation of individuals
and families and it's not realistic to
expect that all residents and visitors
be intimately aware of the potential
threats and hazards that they could be
exposed to at all times an individual or
family in an unfamiliar area of the
state perhaps staying at a vacation
property may be unaware of the potential
consequences of remaining in place and
may misjudge the likelihood of impact
even when considering personal property
and buildings that are very familiar to
the person being asked to evacuate they
may look to try and interpret resources
such as flooded indas maps that are not
as accurate or up to date as many would
like to believe Hazard conditions are
inherently Dynamic weather conditions
change hazardous material plume shift
Direction evacuation routes experience
congestion and the combination of
numerous variables can create a threat
far beyond what was initially expected
in theory the addition of language
saying any person who does not evacuate
such an area upon the recommendation of
the governor shall not receive
additional accommodation or Aid at the
expense of the state sounds reasonable
but repeated experiences across the
country have demonstrated that this is
not realistic we've seen countless
examples during disasters of individuals
and families who initially decided
against evacuating later to decide that
they need help as conditions rapidly
degrade we see heroic examples of First
Responders UNT taking undertaking
extremely risky rescue operations simply
because they see this call for help as
an integral part of their duty to serve
in conditions when when their hands have
been tied due to laws policies or
procedures similar to those outlined in
HP 275 we see an emergence of homegrown
unaffiliated civilian groups that take
it upon themselves to rescue people
under dangerous conditions when Public
Safety organizations are unwilling or
unable these individuals and groups
create numerous complexities in the
emergency response in could pose
additional safety hazards without the
correct training with only a recommended
evacuation more local public safety
entities may be forced to issue conflict
protective actions or make the the
difficult decision of providing Aid when
it is already unsafe to do so ultimately
collaborative Emergency Management
Public Safety and public health teams
work collectively with public uh safe
with subject matter experts to assess
the best available Hazard information
during an impending emergency in order
to recommend protective actions to the
governor the governor's ability to
direct the evacuation of an impacted or
threatened area is a tool that should
not be removed in the mergency
management toolbox the governor is in a
unique position to protect residents and
visitors from hazards that are not bound
or contained by municiple boundaries we
recommend this committee vote
inexpedient to legislate on HB 275 thank
you thank you represent Schmid do you
have a
question I do Madam chair let me just
turn on my camera here so uh Mr Kates uh
you've raised the issue that I wish to
ask the SP the one of the co-sponsors
but but uh the question was deferred to
later but you your testimony raises the
very issue of workability of this this
the bill in many of its uh
manifestations um are you aware of of
any uh state or country for that matter
where uh the the executive uh is
basically uh hands over its required
emergency authority to the leg
legislature um as such as this bill you
know
provides representative I'm not aware of
a situation like that in in Most states
in the country there are emergency um
Provisions to allow for a state of
emergency that enable similar types of
activities to what's seen in RSA 445 but
I'm not aware of any that uh transfer
power uh during that renewal over to the
legislature right followup so uh you
specifically talked about the
legislature being uh you know equipped
to uh to deal with uh situations
involving uh you know study
consideration uh and drawn out periods
of time when emergencies uh require
immediate action uh can you imagine a
situation where the legislature would
get tied up and and the emergency would
uh greatly go uh over the top as a
result of uh the legislature's inability
to act
expeditiously so our primary concern in
in that case would be um
enabling the the quick renewal of uh
state of emergency declaration under
those circumstances where we have a long
duration disaster and we're not even
talking about just simply um covid-19 as
an example this is the first uh that
we've seen where there's been a kind of
this Marathon response uh for almost u a
year and now we're going into over a
year um I I think people don't recognize
that a flood the hurricane some sort of
a major disaster can easily go beyond
that
21-day uh initial state of emergency
requirement and the additional
stipulations added by this bill uh just
really open up a Pandora's Box in
ensuring that that state of emergency
can continue uh without delay into those
uh those coming weeks thank you very
much thank you representative
Shu thank you madam chair I I would just
ask Mr Kates I didn't quite catch his
enti and entire title and job
responsibility could he repeat that
certainly I'm the director of Emergency
Management for the city of nashal thank
you very much
sitech uh Mr Kates uh I'm clerking the
committee and you talked faster than I
could catch your highlights it sounded
like your testimony was written have you
submitted that or would you submit that
please yes I will I'll want to submit it
immediately thank
you seeing no other questions um
is representative BLC
yes I'm here sorry my camera doesn't
seem to be working so it'll have to be
Audio
Only um so yes um thank you madam chair
and um members of the committee uh I
actually helped write this uh bill so I
might would you introduce yourself first
please sure yes this is uh
representative blosic um I um am here to
speak on uh HB 275
um I did uh help pen this um so I'm
hoping that I can answer some of the
questions that um representative Huff
could not answer um Andrew manuse is
also on this call and he also helped uh
write this so I just want to resp
respond to a few points that were made
um I'm not sure how adding legislative
oversight to the state of emergency in
PE
uh emergency response it truly doesn't
change anything about the state of
emergency other than handing some of the
decisionmaking to the legislature and we
did understand when we wrote this that
it may not depending on the emergency
always be possible for
424 members of the legislature to meet
which is why we created what I sort of
consider to be the nuclear option which
is the ability for the executive Ive
Council to
meet um and and continue the the state
of
emergency um as far as the um evacuation
and I know that people had concerns with
the ability of uh law enforcement to
understand this but you know with any
new regulation or law as that comes
about they get retrained on the
situation so I would imagine that that
would be handled um in that way
um so yes if anybody has any specific oh
and the other thing I wanted to address
was the nominal state of emergency
perhaps that's not the right term um
that's possible that maybe we need to
amend that but it what we were hoping to
allow for was the ability to have the
same state of emergency that we
currently have but without handing
unlimited authority over to the
executive branch right now now as our
law is written the executive branch has
unlimited Authority with no oversight
okay and I don't think that there should
always be this where it could go on for
you know an unlimited amount of time uh
with with the governor being able to
make any type of order that he wants so
we we simply wanted there to be an
option that we could be in a state of
emergency without the governor H having
the ability to make um emergency orders
the state of Wisconsin son actually is
attempting to do this with this current
emergency and um the previous uh speaker
said that other states don't have where
the legislature has to approve that is
actually not true there are other states
I I can't remember exactly which one's
off the top of my head but there are
other states where uh a continuation of
the state of emergency requires
legislative
approval thank
you okay representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so representative
blasic thank you for being here uh I'm
very concerned about the idea I'm not
sure whether it's this bill or one of
the others there are several of them as
you know that are pointing in the same
direction uh does it require an an a
unanimous vote of the executive Council
to extend the
emergency yes this is the
one uh so that that goes right to the
question I wanted to ask is it not the
case that one single executive counselor
then has the uh the power uh and is
given the authority actually uh to tie
up the renewal of the state of emergency
is that a workable provision in your
view I guess I would ask the thank you
for your question I would ask the re
rhetorical question of if we were in a
very serious emergency I think everybody
would agree that we are in an emergency
if C Brook you know is taken out I don't
think that there will be a question that
we are truly in an
emergency how about the situation we're
actually in of a pandemic uh
representative Schmid you're getting
hypothetical I'm sorry there's nothing
hypothetical Madam chair about the
pandemic the pandemic is a reality
that's been with us for a year it's not
a h hypothesis at all I'd like an answer
to my question I will answer the
question
um the reality is that RSA 445 was never
written with the intention of handling a
public health
emergency um I could have written
testimony submitted by the authors of
this to that effect um this was intended
for war or for a natural disaster or a
terrorist attack something like that
this was not intended for a disease that
is endemic and I think we are at the
point with this current emergency where
it is no longer necessary to be in a
state of emergency that is my personal
opinion and that's exactly the the
situation that my question goes to if
you
have yeah thank you Mr chairman uh if
you have a situation where one executive
counselor could withhold his or her
approval of extending the the emergency
power of the the governor had claimed
that would hang it up would it
not my opinion is that I would always
prefer to air on the side of Freedom
that is the intention of when we wrote
this law thank you thank you
representative Shu do you have a
question yes thank you madam chair um
I'm just curious representative you you
state that you actually wrote the
language in this bill and yet I don't
see you listed as a co-sponsor
yes
I I just realized that myself IO I guess
I accidentally did not sign off on it um
unfortunately um okay thank
you thank you representative scitech um
um representative blasic um normally
laws are written because some situation
has occurred and we want to prevent it
they're not normally prophylactic but I
guess that can be can you give me
examples of where the governor has
exceeded uh his authority in your view
here I'm not entirely sure how that's
relevant to changing the state of
emergency laws but uh yes the governor
has violated freedom of assembly he has
violated uh freedom of religion um he's
violated part uh part one article 2B of
the New Hampshire state constitution and
part one article 29 and 37 of the New
Hampshire state constitution ution and
the attorney general has argued and the
courts have upheld that the way that the
law is currently written he does have
the right to suspend the Constitution
now I argue that that is not the case
that only during martial law and only
the legislature May uh call for marshal
law declared martial law um but as
things stand right now this law gives
the governor such broad Authority
that he has the right to violate the
constitution if he so
believes that it is necessary in an
emergency so yes we are re I think all
of the bills that are going in this year
to deal with the state of emergency laws
are intended to reign in some of that
unlimited
Authority thank you thank
you representative
goalie thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um we just heard a number of
Articles of the Constitution you cited
that the governor has um what you say
has proposed were
unconstitutional um moves and his
emergency Powers but yet is it not true
you said the courts did not find that uh
true thanks for the question yes um no
the courts did uphold that in bford
versus sonunu back in March that um
because of the way RSA 445 is written it
is written with such incredibly broad
language that he could violate the
constitution and civil liberties if he
feels it is Justified in an emergency
and I don't think that we can allow that
to continue for the next emergency that
exists that's why I we wrote this that's
why uh there are other bills in to start
reigning in Governor
Authority thank
you
represent
fra oh dropped her hand thank you thank
you representative
blazic thank you before we hear from
additional people I'd like to call
Representative trout who is a sponsor
representative gr still had a question I
think that she didn't mean to drop her
hand
oh do you have a question representative
broa
you're
muted I Will Wait thank you okay Madam
chair yes excuse me but I don't see
representative proud listed as a
co-sponsor on this bill either
representative Shu if you you had let me
continue I was going to say he is the
prime sponsor of House Bill
433 which is also about Emergency
Management and that's why we're holding
a joint meeting on these four bills
because they're all
intertwined so are we switching to that
bill now or I'm not sure we are
switching to House Bill 433 and I call
Representative proud you will notice a
market similarity between 433 and
portions of
275 thank
you thank you Madame chairwoman can you
hear me yes thank you I am Andrew Prout
representing Hillsboro County District
37 the towns of Hudson and
pelum the intent of this bill House Bill
433 is to ensure that the legislature is
involved and has a role to approve
long-term states of
emergency I think everyone agrees that
the executive branch needs some ability
to react quickly more quickly than the
legislature can be assembled when an
emergency situation arises and that
makes sense for for the legislature to
delegate Authority for
that however when this emergency
situation persists for an extended
period of time the legislature should
have a
role this bill sets that line at 42 days
12 121 days state of emergency
declaration and one
renewal it also contains a provision for
the clerk of the legislative bodies to
certify that the majority of the members
of the legislature are incapacitated and
by extension that they could not meet
with a quorum in which case the
limitation on the executive is
waved thank you for your time and
consideration I'd be happy to answer any
questions the committee may
have repres representative lonar you had
a
question oh sorry that was delayed I
thought one of our reps was in the
attendees list that's all okay
representative Schmid then thank you
madam chair so representative proud
uh this current situation is exactly the
kind of uh somewhat murky uh situation
that uh my
question uh to the previous
representative was directed at and I'm
going to ask you the same question how
what kind of
workability uh do you have when you have
as we have now a situation which is
viewed very differently uh by members of
the public but also members of the
legislature uh you know with claims that
pandemic is either a serious uh and and
deadly epidemic uh Health situation
other people say it's a hoax doesn't
exist it's this that and what have you
uh is the legislature capable under
those circumstances of acting uh to to
to make the decision to uh extend the
state of emergency when the issue is so
contested uh thank you for the question
uh I think as we've seen both under uh
our current speaker and the previous
speaker both of which who have held
sessions of the new hampter house which
I am going to focus on as the larger of
the two bodies as the more challenging
one to assemble uh during this pandemic
and have done so under uh Public Health
guidelines following Public Health
guidelines that in ways that have made
members from both parties and both uh op
camps of opinion uh feel like they are
able to attend and actually get the
business of the state done and while yes
I think there have been different
opinions about how much the legislature
has met and how much work it has done
versus deferred especially in the
previous term uh I think that one of the
purposes of this bill is to put the
burden back on the legislature to
actually make decisions and actually
exercise its powers as the uh the
Supreme lawmaking authority of the
state thank you thank
you representer
br you have to unmute
yourself thank you representative trout
you mention mentioned in your previous
comment that this would put the burden
back on the shoulders of the legislature
could you speak up
please can you hear me now that's better
thank
you you mentioned um in your previous
testimony that
this the statute put
the back onto the shoulders of the
legislature when did the legislature
ever have this
burden um so the burden I'm speaking of
is being the
uh being the the body that makes laws
and basically sets the direction of the
state and uh I I don't mean to be a
little bit uh flippant but that has been
the the way it has worked since our
constitution was adopted back in the
1700s that the legislature makes the
laws and the executive executes them and
that the legislature is always involved
in uh when laws need to be waved or
changes need to be to be made um so
perhaps I made a little bit
misunderstood your question
uh if that's answered it anyway thank
you okay thank you very
much represent goalie did your question
get
answered yes I'm all set Madam chair
thank you okay
there's no one else who signed up for to
speak on House Bill
[Music]
433 okay thank you representative
proud all right
um all right in that case we
will yes why don't we have
representative leus introduce House Bill
[Music]
414e thank you madam chair um we've
actually had a lot of the discussion on
this because um this handles the issue
um between changing compelling
evacuation in the state of emergency
and changing that to recommend you know
which was incorporated in the
bill so the change is to change the word
compel to recommend and it has language
kind of similar to the previous one it
says at the end provided that the
Emergency Services shall not be required
for those who have chosen not to
evacuate and in the answer to some of
the questions about that raised earlier
I can understand the concern of
Emergency Services feeling that they
have a a duty to help people even if the
people don't want the help and have
refused to uh you know follow the
recommendation to
evacuate but you know my view is people
have a right to decide if they're going
to stay you know where they are or not
and you know that does not you know the
feeling of other people on how they
think they should respond to that
situation um does not create a duty on
those people in my view to leave now
they may be foolish and they may come to
regret their decision but I mean that's
their decision to make in
my thank you madam
chair are there any questions for
representative
uh
[Music]
laus okay representative
Schmidt thank you very much Madam chair
so representative
the the language of the bill though says
you know if you wave your uh your right
to assistance uh you basically uh also
uh you um you give up the right to
assistance you think that that's likely
to be held to be
constitutional um can you hear me with
the microphone there I can hear you
thank you um I don't see how it could
not be constitutional I mean it's been
found all the way up to the Supreme
Court that individ that the uh Emergency
Services have no duty to protect any
particular individual there's actually
been multiple cases that have gone as
far as the Supreme Court that have
clearly stated that uh the case of the
police they don't have a duty to come
and protect you the Supreme Court's
position was they serve a a general
function of theuring crie now I'm sure
that you know police departments fire
departments individ police officers and
firment you know view it differently but
as far as a constitutional question it's
completely clear that
not thank you for taking that
position okay uh represent Mr katees you
had signed up on this bill as well but
uh can I Madam chair I had a question of
the
sponsor representative Shu you have a
question yes thank you you uh
representative leakas um I would call
your attention to in fact one of the
things that Mr Kates mentioned about uh
how do you propose to handle the
situation of someone who first refuses
evacuation and then changes their mind
uh we hear quite often particularly in
cases of major forest fires uh where a
person will
rightfully choose to stay at home to try
and protect their home but then a
firestorm happens and they recant and
decide I better get out of here but then
it's too late um what say you about that
I understand the concern about that
and problems that I pause I would hope I
mean the way the Bill's written if they
refuse evacuation
then um Emergency Services don't have a
further duty to help them I understand
that they they at least they don't have
a legal duty to do so they may feel they
have a duty to do so but you know what I
would suggest is that when they're told
to
evacuate whether it's in person or
through some broadcas that it will make
clear to them that if they refuse the
evacuation when it can be done hopefully
safely that um
they may not they're likely not to get
there's no duty to provide them any
assistance if they change their mind and
hopefully that will you know help people
make a better decision and in the end
you know if that situation you describe
occurs you know my suggestion with the
Emergency Services have plans are
dealing with that and if they can't you
know if it's going to be excessively
dangerous to save the people who have
but refuse to evacuate the plan is if
they don't um if they can do so
reasonably safely and they choose to do
so that's fine if they not
required I think my view is that with
freedom comes responsibility but the
consequences we
CH hope informed choice but in any case
I think that's individual choice to
make thank you representative font
now uh thank you madam chair um my
question is we often uh talk about the
necessity for new or revised legislation
based on something that has or a problem
or fixing a problem of something that
has happened do you have an example of a
of a case in New Hampshire where evacu
evacuation has been
compelled um by the governor but people
have not uh have not complied to that or
there's been an issue with that I don't
have answer that um I mean I wasn't even
aware of the statute until I was looking
at the emergency order
statutes you know in consideration of
current emergency and I was surprised to
see that people could actually be
repel
home and a followup Madam chair follow
up and and would you think that there
would never be a a case where a
compelled evacuation could be
necessary in the in in event of war or
or other
disaster uh no I don't believe it'll be
right under any circumstances to compel
some fact right now you know I might I
might believe and argue that they're
they're being foolish at best crazy at
worse but you know my view is that's
people's right especially know in case
talking about some
reinforcement thank you thank
you representative
goalie thank you madam chair thank you
representative leas for taking my
question uh as I look at this and we've
discussed earlier uh representative
O'Brien brought up First Responders and
having to go after folks if they chose
not to evacuate in due time um my
question is how is it determined that
someone um
has chosen not to evacuate is there a
piece of paper they signed um declaring
that they've given up their rights to do
this or how do we determine that as
First Responders when you see
someone in a house that you feel should
have been evacuated and you don't know
whether or not they chose on their own
or if it's because they couldn't get out
on their own because they didn't have a
means um how do we determine um if this
should happen to go to a court case that
these folks didn't get out for another
other reason other than not choosing so
is there some sort of form or something
that's signed saying that that's their
their
choice first of all as far as court
cases go I don't see there a problem
with court cases as I mentioned before
uh you know I understand that individual
First Responders and departments may you
know lightly I me feel they have a duty
um to rescue people if at all possible
however numerous cases that have on all
as I said all the way at the Supreme
Court multiple times that made it clear
that there is no such Duty and therefore
there should not be a issue now there is
a practical issue you rais of you know
how do Emergency Services deal with this
um at least the emergency evacuation
things I've heard of this it's both
announced publicly on radio TV that sort
of thing U but
also Emergency Services people go
through you know neighborhoods of
notifying people and you know try to
convince a leave and somebody you know
states that they're refusing to
leave then that's the situation now
whether wants to have ask them to sign
something Asos
could draft in some way that's kind of
an operational detail but I don't think
thank you representative
O'Brien thank you Ma Madam chair and
thank you representative for taking my
question um I understand your point that
uh I don't think emergency evacuations
is really
specifically mentioned in the
Constitution but however many states and
there has been uh situations where case
law has been developed and that case law
has been adopted by many other states in
the example of h a fire situation
Michigan versus Tyler which is basically
now has become the law of the land do
you see by writing this particular Bill
jeopardizing or affecting any other area
of current law
that the Fire Marshals and uh the
attorney generals and any others use
those basically Tex laws to uh to affect
their particular business on
particularly for fire situations to keep
the population
safe um thank you for the question um I
have looked at a number of cases uh the
ones that I could find I'm not familiar
with the one specifically mentioned if
you have a I can try and look it up you
know Michigan Tyler but if you got a
better I GL have to and also to do that
to cons send it and also
um you mentioned there maybe some other
cases or other actions by States but if
we put it in statute
that that people refuse to evacuate
there is no further duty to uh to try
and get them out at a later time I don't
see how there'd be a legal problem in
that case
follow up if I may Madam chair yeah to
help the representative out if I may uh
basically uh by uh adopt a law within
our United States and by all states
every single fire is uh that is
unfriendly is constituted as an
emergency so therefore by uh laws and it
is a law of this state too every fire
needs to be investigators to determine
the cause and everything and by doing
that Michigan and Tyler basically says
that the fire department does own the
building until a certain time that they
do have the right to conduct uh a legal
type of investigation now this can be
extended out in many types of things uh
but just to make you aware of it and
that's basically what uh it has to do
with the fire uh fire investigations and
like I say firefighters are compelled by
law to determine the cause because of
the emergency of the situation so I was
just wondering if this could have some
hidden type of effect and uh if this was
approved by any type of review of uh the
Attorney General's office or any other
councel to look to make sure that uh
we're not going to
hamstring uh proper investigations
during an emergency situation
um this would only take effect
um this is under arsa 4453 C which is uh
the governor's power under declared
state of emergency so for uh you know a
normal fire this would not have any
effect at all it's U aimed at more
widespread situations where the governor
has declared a state of emergency over
some portion of the state or the entire
state
so I don't think it would it would have
any impact on a normal fighting of Fire
or the
investigation thank you representative
for taking my question thank you madam
chair representative
Bara
you're muted
Jackie can't hear you trying to stay
muted so in case something falls on the
floor or something excuse me um so the
current statute says that people that
men that evacuations are
mandatory um yes the statute right now
says um this 4453 C under the powers the
governor has under declared state of
emergency to provide for and compel the
evacuation of all or part of the
population from any strien or threatened
area or areas within the state to take
such steps as are necessary for the
receip and care of such Eva needs so it
uses the word
compel followup please follow up and you
do not think that the governor's office
and the information that's provided to
them would
be would support an
evacuation not sure I understand the
question I mean the governor could
recommend evacuation if this uh Bill
were
adopted and with you know providing
whatever information you thought the
office thought was important for people
to know to to convince them to be
vacated they wouldn't that maybe I
misunderstand the question I'm sorry you
do let me clarify it under the current
statute yeah the governor uses the
information that's available to the
governor's office to make that
decision and you don't feel that's
enough to Warrant the statute as it is
correct thank
you other
questions seeing none thank you very
much Mr katees you signed up to speak on
this bill but if your testimony is the
same as it was for House Bill 275
which um I would
[Music]
believe yeah so it is uh the same
concerns particularly around the
language that was added uh stating you
know provided that emergency services
shall not be required for those who have
chosen not to evacuate it just it's not
realistic there's no way uh for us to to
track who has decided not to accept the
offer it just it's not possible so our
Our Testimony is the same and I'll send
a written copy to uh to the email thank
you we've gotten one already actually
thank you for sending
it okay all right uh there's no one else
has signed up for for house build
414 going back to houseu
275 I call Andrew manuse who has signed
up
uh thank you Madame chairman uh and
thank you honorable members of the
committee uh today I present testimony
in favor of HB 275 it's a bill I believe
would change state law to clarify
executive power during a state of
emergency to prude the overreach we have
seen over the past year importantly
there's Provisions that I support in HB
414 HB 47 and HB 433 which are before
your committee as well as HB 277 HB 280
HB 325 HB 559 and HB 389 which are
before the New Hampshire house committee
on leg legislative Administration which
also seek to implement additional checks
on executive power I trust that you're
going to take the best ideas from all
these bills and amend one or two of them
to present the best case reform of our
emergency statutes for adoption uh I
also support hcr2 which would end the
current state of
emergency um I once believed this
dystopian nightmare would be over in
April of 2020 and the fact of the matter
is I I honestly can't believe that I'm
presenting this testimony to you today
as I never would have imagined an
abusive power of this magnitude could be
committed in our Free Republic of New
Hampshire uh part one article 29 of the
State Constitution makes it clear that
only the legislature May suspend or
enact laws in New Hampshire part two
Article 5 makes it clear that these same
laws may not be repugnant to the
Constitution arguably RSA 445 has
written should align with these
principles and in section 3E it should
be clear that the governor's authority
to perform and exercise such other
functions powers and duties as are
necessary to promote and secure the
safety and protection of the civilian
population does not give him or her
authority to suspend law make new law or
suspend the Constitution but during this
protracted nightmare the governor has
done all three things in fact when it
comes to the institution of emergency
orders written under the supposed
authority of this section the chief
executive and his departments have
written new policy enforced the same
policy and created an adjudication
process for the same policy effectively
giving the executive branch legislative
executive and judicial functions this
directly violates part one article 37 in
the State Constitution which states that
the legislature executive and judicial
ought to be kept as separate from and
independent of each other as the nature
of a free government will admit in other
words a state of emergency does not
erase or minimize the legisl or judicial
branches and yet in practice these other
two branches have been largely missing
in action granted the legislature could
at any time vote to Ender the state of
emergency under RSA 445 and I argue that
it should have back in April 2020 at any
point since any day since it was clear
that there would be no catastrophic
curve to flatten and we were simply
dealing with a really bad virus that any
free people could handle with commonly
known hygiene techniques and a little
guidance and I truly mean the word
guidance from a true definition from
Health officials however the word
guidance has morphed into law and the
legislature has been sideline and doing
its constitutional Duty and so far has
not taken back its power I'm asking you
to change that now importantly one
reason the legislature has struggled to
end the state of emergency is precisely
because the executive branch has set up
a new government running by itself under
the color of Law and ending the state of
emergency would unravel that new
government this is what all of the bills
I've mentioned once they become law
would prevent from ever happening again
now I like HB 275s provisions and have
chosen to speak directly on this bill
because it's so eloquently and firmly
plants The Authority for extending a
state of emergency into the hands of the
legislature where it belongs and it
preserves autonomy in the hands of the
people to govern themselves even in the
midst of chaos because in America we
believe the people know best how to
manage their own lives and the lives of
those around them while the bill
provides for contingency plans for True
emergencies during which the legislature
cannot meet it also provides strict
penalties to the government during this
time period so that the emergency cannot
be extended Beyond its reasonable life
the governor ought to have the right to
declare a state of emergency after all
he or she is managing the day-to-day
operations of the state and will have
access to the most up-to-date
information however the governor ought
to be checked before extending a state
of emergency to prevent abuse use of
power particularly like we've seen in
the last year at no point May the same
Governor employ his or her state of
emergency to enact new laws or suspend
them which HB 275 Section 3 E's addition
under the law clarifies language in 3A
of HB 275 ensures there is no confusion
with this uh principle spe specifically
the language clarifies that the governor
may use current laws to suspend rules or
regulations written by his or her
departments to adjust to an emergency
situation and potentially reallocate
resources between departments as the law
allows but by no means May the executive
make up new rules or regulations or
suspend laws without going through the
legislative process and he or she may
never suspend constitutional rights not
even the legislature can do that we
elect the legislature of 425 men and
women 24 sorry precisely because we dis
agree on how best to manage the state
and it is in that disagreement and
compromise that we come up with a sound
policy that is suitable for the most
people ideally that policy creates a
rule of law that governs everyone
equally so that even the minority is
protected by it as this process has been
thwarted over the past year we have seen
one man and his team of Executives craft
policy that may uh or may not take
everything else into consideration and
whether the policy has been Sounder or
not it has not been properly vetted
under the Constitutional system that we
have set up to make sure that it is we
have to stop this from continuing and we
have to prevent this from happening
again thus the governor should not have
the authority to extend a state of
emergency not even once after 21 days
the legislature if not the whole state
should have the ability to to get up to
speed on what is actually happening and
make an informed judgment as to whether
the emergency persists on top of
enabling this the bill also provides
metrics for measuring what the state of
emergency actually consists of and
conditions that would be needed to end
it which creates a bright line for
policy makers to
use Excuse me I got a phone
call um the bill lows provides metrics
for measuring what the state of
emergency actually consists of and
conditions that would be needed to end
it which creates a bright line for
policy makers to use as they judge
whether or not to continue it if the
whole legislature can't meet because the
emergency truly is that bad then the
executive Council unanimously may choose
to continue the state of emergency to
enable emergency measures to continue
and yes uh representative Schmidt I do
believe that one executive counselor in
his wisdom and judgment should be able
to stop a state of emergency from
happening as it is right now we have one
governor who's making that judgment and
I think he's making the wrong one and so
I do believe he needs a check on his
authority to ensure that it's truly
impossible for the legislature to meet
under this provision the poison pill is
added removing tax revenue from the
state and from cities and towns which
will motivate the legislature to get
back together and do the job it was
elected to do for the people of the
state as soon as conceivably possible
ideally the legislature should be making
policy decisions at all times and the
executive ought to be enforcing those
policies the situation that lasts longer
than 42 days cannot possibly still be an
emergency that requires abandonment of
the Constitutional process and the
Republic that was set up to defend the
people's ability to govern themselves
even in the worst of times the idea
behind the changes proposed by HB 275
are that the people should always be in
charge of their government through their
legislature and they also ought to keep
autonomy over their own lives property
and businesses I urge you to pass it
though I acknowledge that many of the
great ideas and the other bills before
you also present solutions to the
problems I've highlighted and I do trust
you as a committee will amend one or two
of these bills to incorporate the best
ideas to strengthen the legislature's
role in handling future states of
emergency into a bill that becomes law I
do want to address a few of the things
that have come up in
conversation um you know briefly that
ends my testimony which I have submitted
to you by email uh um the First
Responders forcing people out of their
home or
businesses um I would I would submit to
you that under a true
emergency uh a reasonable person is
going to listen to the authority figure
and leave that scene upon
request um however if that person does
not choose to leave that scene they they
have an awfully good reason for it and
by there there should be no force in any
situation whatsoever where a person is
required ired by the government at the
point of a gun to leave their own
property that is just wrong and it's
unamerican the uh the second thing is a
nominal State of Emergency the the purp
maybe the the term nominal is is uh you
know not the right term to use and I
certainly welcome your your suggestions
to amend that term but um the point of
it was that sometimes a state of
emergency um leads to a a different type
of state of emergency which can be
Financial um in the instance of covid-19
in particular um it was the governor's
response to covid-19 that actually
caused the real emergency and now we do
have some Financial emergency that
requires Federal funding to keep us uh
in in a state of um you know solvency if
you will and and that is the state of
emergency so maybe it's a Financial
State of Emergency if you want to use
those terms but the point of the matter
is that the governor ought not to have
the power to craft emergency orders and
that is the problem that we're
attempting to address he should not be
governing the state and also writing the
state's laws it is the legislator's job
to to craft state laws and if the laws
are not sufficient it is your job to
change them um whether uh someone also
brought up urgency of the state of
emergency in the executive having I
believe it was the gentleman from nashwa
and the urgency of having the ability to
respond in Rapid format in the
legislature's slow response time um I
would submit to you that after 21 days
there is no reason that the House and
Senate could not get together and pass a
house concurrent resolution or even just
a house resolution that gives guidance
to the executive department on how to
proceed in including extending the state
of emergency under the uh conditions
that are outlined in our bill HB 275
that's a critically important section of
the bill um in in in terms of uh you
know an obligation to protect or
lawsuits I believe uh uh it was either
representative goalie or O'Brien who
brought this up um there are there is
several uh case law um including US
Supreme Court decisions that indicate
that there is no duty to protect
whatsoever um it is simply uh a matter
of law
uh that we have provided this service
however it is not an obligation of our
First Responders to protect the people
it is the people's uh obligation to
protect themselves and they do that at
their own voluntary uh you know M mind
with using their own voluntary decisions
and wisdom and if they want to follow
the guidance of the state because the
state does have uh some ability to
accumulate wisdom uh and and and
expertise in the form of our First
Responders then is their right to do
that as well but for those who do not
want to follow the guidance it is their
right not to and I would submit to you
that at the point of a gun you've
created a mini War where um someone who
doesn't want to leave their house is
going to die one way or the other
whether it's from the disaster itself or
from being shot by the first responder
and I don't mean to uh be flippant with
that comment but that's what you're
actually doing if you take your argument
to the point of its conclusion so I
would argue to you that all interaction
should be volunt in a free society and
that is the point of this bill is to
restore voluntary interactions as well
as to restore power to the legislature
where it ought to be thank you ladies
and gentlemen Representatives I
appreciate your
time representative scitech has a
question I have just one question Mr
manuse um if the legislature can end the
state of emergency at any time by
resolution why do you think they're
going to buy into this legislation
um I I suppose that's a question for the
424 members when they decide to vote on
uh this
legislation um I I do know that hcr2 is
being heard today in a different
committee I've already testified on that
representative sitech and I I testified
in
favor um as I'm sure you could assume um
and I think it is well pass due time for
the legislature to do just that
uh but the point of these bills all of
the ones I've mentioned here is not to
end the state of emergency it is but to
protect uh the state in the future so
that when there is another situation
that warrants a state of emergency to be
called that there are added checks and
balances to make sure that one man does
not have ultimate power and authority to
do whatever he wants perhaps this one
man who happens to be our governor right
now has made wise decisions and I'm not
going to begrudge him or even get into
his decisions on this matter maybe you
agree representative citac that he has
made good decisions um I don't know
whether you have you do or don't but
that's neither here nor there the point
of the matter is that one man should not
have that role and Authority that power
has been vested in an elected
legislature which represents the people
of this state and it is the people of
this state who ought to govern
themselves
representative
Shuan Madam chair um representative
manuse uh when representative BLC
testified she mentioned that you and she
basically wrote the language of House
Bill
275 and yet uh as with her I don't see
your name listed as a sponsor may I ask
why
not well that's a very easy question to
answer representative Shu I am not a
representative uh I'm just a man who uh
has the ability to write and yes I did
um put some time in and help write this
bill um I'm happy to answer any
questions about the bill because of
that thank you are you not my
error I was a representative in 2011 and
12 that thought I remembered the
name um Madam chair I do have one other
question
um Mr manuse uh you you mentioned that
you felt that uh the executive powers
that the governor is enacting uh have
been shown to be an abuse of power um
but would you not say that the
overwhelming electoral support that the
governor received in the midst of this
pandemic while we were all handling
these emergency pow shows that the vast
majority of the citizens of New
Hampshire felt that the governor was not
abusing his power thank you um that's a
really great question representative Shu
and I really appreciate it um part of
the question is political and I if you
want my opinion please ask in a followup
I'll be happy to provide my opinion of
why the governor was reelected but it's
a political question and I don't think
it's
Germain um but I do want to you know
explain that we don't live in a
democracy where the majority rules or
the most praised or popular idea wins
the day uh we live in a republic uh and
even the best ideas ought to be vetted
and held up to the standard of law
written into the Constitution to ensure
that the majority's rights are protected
I'm going to give you an example if 99
people of a 100 think that one person's
land that he purchased and developed
under the law is better suited to
another private purpose
you know it doesn't matter we have a
constitutional provision that we
actually passed fairly recently that
prohibits that majority from taking the
land because that one person has a right
to the land the point of the example is
that we have laws in the state that you
may have even helped WR yourself and
these laws are being disregarded right
now by our executive and they shouldn't
be the Constitution makes clear that
only the legislature or the people have
the authority to suspend or create laws
the governor and other executive branch
officials don't have have this Authority
in a state of emergency they still don't
have that Authority yet they've claimed
it so what I'm asking you to do uh is to
do what is right under the rule of law
and under our Republican form of
government and and you know clarify RSA
445 to indicate to this Governor or any
other Governor that comes after him that
they don't have the authority to suspend
the Constitution that they don't have
the authority to authority to suspend
laws or make new ones and that that
power is vested only in the legislature
which is what the Constitution says but
I do believe it needs to be clarified
and and because of the testimony of
Representative blasic that she made
earlier it's very clear that it does
need to be clarified uh particularly
following the Benford ruling um so that
is uh that is what we're asking you to
do as a legislature as our
representatives of the the people at
large in this
state thank
you representative fno you have a
question thank you madam chair um and
thank you for taking my question just a
kind of a quick follow up on the same
question I had asked representative
luckus on the previous bill is that on
the section of compel versus recommended
uh for evacuation you kind of indicated
that we may see a situation where First
Responders are shooting um people for
not evacuating do you know or do you
have an example of where that may have
occurred in the past that that would
indicate this is a problem we need to
deal with representative Fort new I hope
I pronounced your name correctly um I
appreciate the question um the the
comment was made in uh hyperbole
intended to show that if you take the
um the law as it's written to its
logical conclusion you're forcing
someone out of their home or business
force is you know ultimately results at
the end of a point of a gun um if
someone is not willing to comply with
that Force um so while I don't know of
that ever happening I do know that it is
a person's right to stay in their home
if they so choose and the government
should not force them to leave and
that's the point of this
provision thank
you any other
questions all right thank you thank you
very much thank
you all right no one else has signed up
to speak on house
bills 414 433 or
275 414 yes sorry that case we will move
on to House Bill 4117 and I call
Representative Roy to introduce
it can you hear
me can you hear me there you are yep can
you hear
me yes representative Roy we can hear MC
thank you thank you um so uh hello
colleagues um I'm introducing House Bill
417 um
so this bill is a little different than
the ones we've heard discussed over the
last hour or so I too think that there
um there needs to be some revamping of
the of the governor's U powers during
this but what I don't want to do um is
get down into the weeds um the governor
is the executive and ero the manager and
and the legislature I don't think has a
position um as management we can't mic
micromanage emergencies so what I've
done in this bill is I've if the
governor still has the same powers to
declare a state of emergency matter of
fact I've extended it to 30 days and he
can renew that state of emergency and
I've left alone the ability of the house
and the Senate through concurrent
resolution to terminate it but if he
extends the state of emergency he has to
come to the
legislature and he has to get our
approval for executive orders that are
issued after that point
so that allow the flexibility for him to
do what he needs to do in emergent
situations and it also gives us the
oversight to look at these executive
orders now I've put a provision in there
that says if we can't for some reason
get together within three days the
executive orders in state of emergency
I'll extend for 14-day increments until
we can manage to get together I put
something in there where the governor
has to help us out and if there's a
natural disaster where the roads are
closed or washed out um he has to use
his ability and be it state troopers or
what have you to help us get to the
legislature to help out in this um and I
left it a simple majority of the house
to make it less complicated um if we had
put the House and Senate it would have
been much more complicated I put a
majority of the house president voting
no super majorities I just feel like
once you get past that 30 days and the
nature of the emergency is such that
it's going to continue the people do
have a right to have their voice heard
um
so if we look at the number of emergency
orders that been existed um or issued
under this emergency the people have had
absolutely no say in them um we just
have to take them and it is what it is I
think that at a certain point these
emergency orders become laws I mean
literally the executive is governing um
with one branch and has been for a
year um and that's not to criticize him
or or his orders or whether to second
guess or judge the this is prospective
looking forward do we want to end up in
a situation like this again where we
have one branch of Governor government
running state for a year um and I think
the answer to that is clearly no we have
a duty it's our job to get in there and
actually work with the executive on
these things so um I'll I'll keep it
short at that and I'm happy to take
questions thank you representative Roy
are there
questions yes I have a question yes
representative Schmid thank you madam
chair so thank you for talking to us
Terry about your feelings on this uh so
but the
the without getting into it into a
debate with you uh you say the the
governor is running the state that's
what the executive branch does it runs
the state uh but and and and I'd like
you to to disagree with that if you if
you don't see it that way uh but uh his
the legislation you referred to is
strictly to implement his executive
orders which are legal under the under
the statute so uh and is it really
workable the idea that in the legis that
the legislature is going to come back in
we're we're only in session from January
until June roughly okay the rest of the
year we're not in session how do we get
back in
session ordinarily the governor calls us
into special session so uh most of the
time year for year there is no uh
legislature there to uh no house there
in order
to do this resolution that you're
proposing how workable is your Solution
that's my
question thank you representative Schmid
your first question I agree the
Governor's job is to run the state um
and by run the state in the reference
that I used he's running the state um
he's he's taking over two branches of
the three of government he's passing
executive um orders that have the effect
of Law and you know within a short
period of time that's reasonable when
you start getting into years which we're
about to cross over um I think it's you
know at some point we have to say hey
okay um we need to come back now as for
your second part question the the
governor would have to call us back as
it as is written in that in that uh in
the proposed bill um so that we could
opine on this and weigh in and work with
him on on future executive orders so I
think it's entirely feasible um
especially if there were a state of
emergency like this for us to come back
um and I I believe it it especially
seeing as I left it to a majority of
President voting and not you know the
have to assemble the entire 400 person
body depending on what type of emergency
it was that may not be feasible but at
least get the people's I mean the the
People's most direct representatives are
us um so if if the majority of us agrees
with the governor then we can be assured
that the majority of the state agrees
with the governor and that's not to to
compared to you know um his polling or
or how he did in the election it's
directly gerain to whatever the
executive order is because our
constituent will reach out to us and we
will be their voice I hope that answers
your
question I thank you for your position
representative Shu do you have a
question yes Madam chair thank you good
morning representative Roy um just
curious uh following up sort of with
what you just said that uh just a
majority of the house would have to do
this but um under this current pandemic
we could not even get back into the
state house and it took quite some time
for the means to get even a majority of
us to be able to have a place to meet um
and how do you feel that plays against
the needs of dealing with an emergency
situation thank you representative Shu
that's an important point which is why
um I included in there an automatic
extension if we were unable to meet in
14-day increments so that we would have
time to figure out how to do this how to
get together um you know without without
getting into the politics of whether or
not we should or should be meeting where
we should be meeting or
how the governor can extend these in
14-day increments until we can get back
together now if we can't figure out a
way to get back together in three months
he will just continue extending the
14-day increments and so be it um but
the goal is that we should have we
should have a an impetus to get back and
figure out how to do this to to help him
uh manage you know the state and the
people's business so I would I would I I
was very careful not to limit his
ability to deal with emergencies because
of us but I was trying to do is make
sure we had a way to be aart and have a
seat at the
table thank you representative legro
morning representative Ro thank you for
taking my question um isn't the uh the
fact that we can't be in the state house
and uh having limited having
difficulties
communicating in fact a direct uh result
of the governor's
orders and uh is there anything that
could prevent the governor under current
statute from just saying I'm
suspending uh the house uh
deliberations he also an
emergency um thank you theoretically um
I'm sure it would end up at the state
supreme court in about an hour but
theoretically he could um and you are
correct that the reason that we uh
originally did not return to reps Hall
is because of the governor's emergency
order that dictated how many people
could be where and and there's also the
the the obvious Public Health aspect of
it um but but you're correct but which
is why I was very careful to give him
that initial 30 days so that he can
react on his feet and he can do what he
has to do
um but after 30 days I think that we
should be able to get in there and U
figure out a way to do
it yes I will say that we the house did
in fact meet within 60 days after the
start of
the for the first session at
un follow question follow and and just
um I appreciate the the
attentive this can very quickly devolve
into just a political exercise for
instance
um in any given state or at least in
this state the state uh Supreme Court uh
justice I'm sorry
the Chief Justice of the state supreme
court is recent political appoint by
Coincidence of this Governor so it
worries me that this could rapidly
devolve into a political
situation is this a further reason why
the state legislature the
representatives of the people should at
some point be involved
Absol absolutely thank you for the
question um it it should be involved to
take the politics out of it um you know
as I said we being the 400 member body
are the most direct representatives of
the people in allowing us to have a um
ability to input and approve or
disapprove of these things that are
directly going to impact our
constituents lives um is the most
constitutional way to handle um
something that on its faces is
unconstitutional so um it's a it's a
conundrum and I tried as best as I could
to walk a thin line to give that
executive the ability to respond with
still allowing us to say the people
agree or disagree than representative
Pearson thank you madam chair
representative Roy I just I want a
little bit of
clarification on something you just said
did you did you stti that the governor
could tell the Speaker of the House the
speaker of the house could not hold or
call the body into
session um I I think I preface that by
saying theoretically I think I don't
think there's a theoretical here I think
that the separation of powers are pretty
clear the Speaker of the House can call
the house into session when that speaker
chooses answer the question thank you
representative um it does say that the
loss is a lot of other things too that
that have been that have been waved um
so that's why I said theoretically um
theoretically the Speaker of the House
can do whatever the Speaker of the House
wants is's a separate entity um having
said that it also says that the
legislature shall make laws and right
now the executive is making laws so um
it comes down to again a fine line and
and that was I would suppose a a
hypothetical question by the
representative taking the argument to
you know ad of serum almost but um when
you're talking about unlimited
unfettered power that so far has not
been checked by us or the court um you
know I guess you get into the the
question of where will it end or what
will stop
it yes representative
Broda thank you madam chair good morning
representative Roy morning represent so
um the executive orders of the governor
has will no longer be viable once the
restive orders are rescinded
correct um do you mean once the
emergency state of emergency has res
sended yes that is
correct so these are not really laws
they are they're not permanent laws
correct um well I I I guess you start
getting into relative questions about
how long how long at what point do they
become laws if the state of emergency
goes on another year and it's now two
years are they still law are they still
just orders or are they laws I mean it's
a relative question um I imagine the
people that have to live under them
during the duration of the emergency
order will pretty much feel their laws
especially if they're fined or
incarcerated for violating one of them
but I I your point is taken that at some
point one would presume they will
eventually
expire thank you representative
Schmidt we thank you madam chairman so
but isn't it the case that that all
these bills that we're hearing this
morning are basically strictly in
response to the extraordinary
circumstance of the pandemic which is
lasting uh far beyond what a what a
snowstorm a fire or even a flood would
impose on the state and its citizens or
a particular part of the state and and
and it's very contentious with regard to
uh what the actual reality of the
pandemic is uh the people on the right
tend to say this is a a hoax uh The
Masks don't work uh and uh our freedom
our freedoms are being taken away from
rep yes representative Schmidt I would
hope you hope you do not broad brush
large portions of the
state what is your
question the question is is this this
not these these bills that we're hearing
this morning are they not all in
response to the emergency situation that
exists right now because of the pandemic
which is an extraordinary circumstance
which we have not seen in a hundred
years uh the all the other kinds of
emergencies are over are over and done
with in a very short period of time um
and there's no question about it it's
it's it's a contentious political issue
right now regardless of how you want to
characterize it with regard to how
people believe but go into the stores
and you'll see that overwhelmingly
everybody's wearing a mask in the cities
at at the very least I answer the
question okay so
um I'll try to still that down to it
sounds like you're asking is Would we
not be writing these bills were it not
for the nature of this pandemic versus a
regular emergency and the answer is
actually yes um but what this has done
has showed us what can happen with the
law as written um I don't believe that
there's any U indication that we won't
have another pandemic or that something
like this couldn't happen again so it's
best that we prepared for it I believe
that's why I've been very careful not to
critique any of the actions or take a
position on on the on the validity or
worthiness of any of the executive
orders
but
prospectively should another uh you know
let's say this one ends next month and
then in December some type of new virus
shows up or a bacteria or what have you
we should be um prepared to assist and
do our role as a co- branch of
government and not once again turn the
keys over to the executive and say you
know do what you got to do for however
long it takes so there's a definitely a
political aspect as is every every piece
of legislation we do but I'm try to make
make this bill as apolitical as possible
um and you know it by leaving it up to
majority the house that's the most
representative you're going to get of
the people in the state regardless of
their party so be it a republican
Democrat Governor majority not majority
it's just about representatives of the
people okay I appreciate you taking a
position on this representative
sht thank you madam chair um
representative just uh extrapolating
what you've been
saying um would it be my understanding
that the lawsuit that the legislature
tried to early on in this pandemic to
have the governor uh particularly take
some of his financial decisions through
the house fiscal committee was um an
appropriate um method to try and have
the legislature in
um I I I really can't and won't aine on
on any litigation that happened but I
can tell you that that would not have
been necessary had this statute been
enacted because um he would have had to
come to the legislature to U pass any
orders that had to do with financial
situations after 30 days so it would
have made it a moood
point representative
goalie thank you madam chair and thank
you representative Roy for taking my
question uh one quick question if it's
going to be a truly representative bill
should it not be both the House and
Senate votes not just the
house and thank you for the question I I
tried to um you're correct in that it
could be more representative uh by
adding the Senate it could be more
representative by adding the executive
uh Council um we could even included I
suppose a Justice of the Supreme Court
um but I tried to make this as narrow as
possible to streamline it and keep his
ability to keep things flowing um
without getting two different political
bodies involved in it to have to agree
or disagree a simple up or down vote I
felt um would move along quicker and it
would be more decisive um should the
commune it's in its wisdom decide that
the Senate needs to be included um I
wouldn't object that the Senate however
I left that alone where the only way to
end the state of emergency is concurrent
with the House and Senate they are still
involved in that but as far as the
day-to-day executive orders I felt that
it would be a much more streamlined
process to have one body to
it thank you my just thought in that was
the House and Senate have to pass
legislation together in order to get it
to the governor's desk that they should
both be included when they do
this your point is well taken
representative thank
you uh
representative Roy would you can you
hear me now yeah that's better thank you
uh would you object to having the Senate
added in um you know there is previous
speaker was correct that normally the
Senate's involved in
passing well practical matter I'm a
little concerned how the Senate would
view this bill we're cutting them out
thank you I fully anticipated they would
have added themselves back in anyway so
um I'd be happy to add them back in um
it was no slight to The Honorable
Senators it was as I said a a a well to
address the first point agreed the
legisl uh the legislature and the Senate
House and Senate have to work together
to pass laws these aren't laws these are
executive orders that need the approval
so I I differentiated it a little bit
there it is a little bit different
because if you think about it kind of a
an odd situation where the executive
would be writing a law that we would
have to pass versus US writing a law
that he would have to sign so um again
I'm happy to add them back I would not
object to that at all I did that for
streamlining purposes um
only are there other questions for
representative Rock come on I'm on a
roll
excellent I don't see any either uh is
there any member of the public who has
has not spoken who testify on any one of
these if they do please raise your
hand
ra okay seeing
none that case we are I will close the
public
hearing it's now 10 minutes to
12 we are
have
a a work session on these bills at 1:30
or after the after the hearing is over I
think we will declare it to be
1:30 and go and go from there that'll
give us time to to stretch our legs and
work out and think about this and then
this afternoon we will discuss these
issues and see if we can find reach some
agreement on some
[Music]
we will resume at
1:30 mam chair I would presume that
we're going to need to stay logged in to
our this Zoom session or is that or log
into it again either way your choice
okay thank you all see you at
1:30
zo at
one30
okay
who's
sanago
[Music]
making myself valuable
to it's always useful to have more SK
that
and I was something
about
yeah
F myself
Sor oh goodbye
you're talking to
somebody that my older
sistered
Mark tried to turn it
on all right one i' like to to make a
comment before we get going the U we I
don't plan to vote on any of these bills
today because um I I think that some of
the testimony was correct that we need
to
consider combining them and only coming
up
with with one bill at a
time so we are meeting on Thursday at
10:30 to exact the state of the weather
statutes and um probably 544 and as many
others as we can get
to
list of the bills
that represent saso when you get a
chance unmute yourself and tell us where
you are who's with
you
you need me to do that as well Madam
chair uh if you didn't check in yes did
you yes I am in conquered in my home and
my husband will be in and out of the
room
okay
for
[Music]
I
up
it's 1:30 so we're in a full committee
work session on these bills and I have a
point of an area that hasn't been
discussed yet that I'd like to bring to
your
attention one of the things that
bothered me about the state of emergency
was that the governor declared it and
said we have
to uh take preventive actions to flatten
the curve and prevent our hospitals from
being overwhelmed which makes sense the
time but then as time went on he kept
changing why he needed to continue the
state of
emergency and I thought that was rather
disconcerting you
know uh one of these bills I think it's
274 has language that says that the
Declaration of the state of
emergency has to
specify what conditions are necessary to
extend the state of emergency and I
think that's a very important factor
because
you know if we have an emergency because
we're likely to get
our um you know hospitals are likely to
get flooded with with cases well okay we
have an emergency
but you know 21 days later it's we're
having the same emergency for a
different reason that just struck me as
as wrong and I wanted to bring that
point
up
[Music]
Madam chair yes yes if I may um I'll
just point out that I think when
representative sh but represent leus was
recognized first oh I'm sorry I couldn't
hear
him as I think said
earlier Works session process so I don't
know if at this point we should just
response to that actually agree
with to
bring
separate I I think I can't hardly hear
him he's breaking up is that better yes
that's better I guess I need to get
closer um I agree with um with
representative McGuire's point the
chair's point I was going to say is all
these bills and my bill 414 is kind of
separate I think but of the actual state
of emergency bills um I think the one
that's kind of uh cleanest one I don't
think there's a real problem with in my
view is
433 and so might want to think about um
taking other things we might feel are
necessary such as uh this addition of U
44 part one e the conditions necessary
and you know maybe tack them onto here
um and 433 is the main idea is that the
governor can do a 21-day state of
emergency and one extension
only um it says unless the clerk of
either chamber of the legislature and
assistant clerk pursuant to RSA 44 as
certified within the past seven days
basically that that know it's it's not
possible to have a session of the of the
legislature
um and and um but unless the legislature
really can't meet then you know the
legislature has to extend it after in
effect 42
days I like that idea because um while
the legislature can end the state of
emergency I think there's a real
Temptation for various reasons to just
you know abdicate the legislator
abdicating its responsibility sitting
back and letting the governor do it and
as represents the people I think that if
at all
possible um at you know after after the
first bit of the emergency the uh the
legislature really needs to get
followed show
up thank you madam chair um I was just
going to point out uh with reference to
your statement of one reason and one
reason only for a state of
emergency I think in this particular
case when it
first no one could have foreseen the
length of time that this disease was
going to insert itself into our lives
and as we saw later on uh October and
November of last year actually did
almost overrun our hospitals the number
of cases increased so greatly uh I can
see with something that's longterm such
as this that the reasons that you need
the emergency could easily
change and to be honest the executive
branch is probably better equipped to
adapt to those changes than the
legislative branch would be that's my
opinion thank
you
schelz thank you madam chair um I still
need to read through the bills some more
and I'm sad that I'm because of my bill
presentation and other committee that I
didn't hear all of the testimon on all
the bills but I felt one bill might come
close to what I had hoped when I heard
that Republicans were considering
bringing forth uh concerns over the um
executive orders from the governor
because there certainly is a point of
agreement if we can find the right way
to get to that H in a bipartisan way I
think that uh maybe not all Democrats
but I I suspect many Democrats will um
support a certain way of addressing this
maybe it's HB 417 I certainly think
representative Roy's presentation
appealed to me and I think you have at
least one Democrat as a co-sponsor that
representative Vil is representative Sue
Vil from uh
NASA um I think
that I do think it so let me just
outline just some thoughts that I have
around that in with the hopes that it
will help whatever amendments or however
we focus this as we go at least for my
point of view as one of the Democrats I
think
that executive orders for a year is uh
excessive I think that we've been in
session should have um brought us back
to a mode of cooperating as three
coinkle branches of government
I think we could have done that a long
time ago uh through special sessions and
I think that would have been the right
way to go I feel um there has been quite
a bit of
overreach and I think to my
constituents Republican or Democrat the
governor has seemed
to um and this isn't a disparagement
this is just uh why I think we'll come
to an agreement as Democrats and
Republicans in the
legislature um I feel it seems like
through the governor's presentations on
W and from his press conferences he has
a unique ability to seem to appeal to
folks that usually differ on big issues
around covid but when you drill it down
for example just the mask issue alone
even retailers are frustrated from folks
who agree with my point of view on masks
that they're there isn't really any
teeth to it on the other side I hear
some arguments of people who disagree
with me and my view on masks that make
actually some interesting arguments that
are frustrating for all of us I think
that bringing
Clarity to this debate around how New
Hampshire responds to covid to the
federal Finance piece to what is
actually needed with that money
I think the latitude that the governor
has used has been too broad it has been
um
often uh in my
opinion uh even the Gopher committee
that has some legislative uh
representation many of their
recommendations have gone ignored I
think if the legislature could have
played a role fairly quickly we could
have prevented a lot of these
difficulties and um for businesses for
sure for General citizens for how we
just function as a society I think there
have been breakdowns and luckily not so
much of a breakdown that it's been utter
chaos but I think
that I hope that we can find common
ground because at the root of this whole
discussion is a broad reach of power
from one branch of government at the
expense of other branches of government
especially the legislative branch and I
couldn't agree more with that overall
and I hope that people smarter than me
on this committee can help us drill down
to those points where we do agree and I
think there are places where we're
definitely going to agree and perhaps HB
417 is a good starting point I have a
lot of other thoughts but I'm not GNA
say them all I'll let other people speak
save them for round two representative
goalie
thank you madam chair and I will um
probably say some similar things as
representative Schultz just said because
I think this
is where we are here is trying to make
the determination of
whether we need to talk about declaring
the state of emergency and how long the
state of emergency is declared
for
and differentiate that between that and
the executive orders that are declared
by the governor um I think we all
have um our opinions on the way we want
to go with this um I
believe the governor having the right to
declare the state of emergency and given
those 21 days um and then the
legislature has their ability to if they
no longer feel it is needed to resend
that uh emergency declaration by a
concurrent resolution I think that
problem in my mind is taken care of the
issues I have are with the executive
orders and I I think there needs to be
some sort of accountability after a
certain time frame uh that needs to be
addressed and uh representative Roy's
bill goes in that direction I think with
some work um we could probably come to
some common ground and get there um
we're looking to do um so those are the
few points I want to make that there is
the two different factors declaring the
state of in how long and I think the
oversight of the executive orders and
with that thank you m chair Madam chair
if I could I can't raise my hand because
I'm a co-host oh uh thank you it
is um I just wanted a a a point that
just occurred to me is you know we can
right now resend the state of emergency
if with the Senate and the house
concurrent the problem is is that by
letting the executive orders go so long
to use a a kind of a tired term it's
become too big to fail if if we were to
just resend it right now that would
cause utter chaos because the executive
orders have spiderweed into so many
aspects of government and Civil Life
that it would just be a disaster so I
think that the that was my point in the
bill I drafted was let's get ahead of
these executive orders before they
become so much that you can't simply
just vote them out because if we were to
do that right now I I agree that it
would be it would be
bedum
O'Brien uh thank you madam chair um my
question and in in looking at 417 which
is uh out of all of them is the one
probably I might like the best but the
other elephant in the room it seems to
be wanting the legislature to limit the
U the governor's ability to declare
the state of emergency but I got to ask
the question what happens if it's a lot
in reverse that let's say in the example
of the pandemic that we had a govern
governor who did not believe in face
masks who did not believe in Social
distancing who did not believe in some
of the recommendations by some of our
local Board of Health or uh the CDC from
the federal government so while we're
while we open up the can of tuner on
this should we basically look at it to
empower the legislator legislature
itself to be able to declare a state of
emergency I believe it is
already okay thank you mad Chief because
that I did not see in the bill but
doesn't mean it didn't exist I just
didn't say it and was unaware yeah it's
not in the bill it's in the statute the
on the bill it just shows the amendments
to the statute plus I think that we
could um we could literally just pass
laws and if we had to override a veto
too
so I thank you for the clarification
thank you representative
Schmid thank you madam chair so um I I
do think that it's not at all
inappropriate for us to uh to work on
something I don't think frankly that any
of the bills are ready to be uh
passed into law at this point uh but but
I do think that representative Roy's
Bill provides a you know a structure
that we could look at to to address some
of the issues that are out there we
we've already addressed uh in this
Colley we're having now some um some uh
grievances that the Democrats had with
regard and possibly some Republicans as
well with the the governor's uh know
decision to ignore the joint fiscal
committee um and create his own U you
know toothless uh committee to uh to
advise him I don't know if he adopted
any of their recommendations but they
didn't have any power to to enforce
anything anyway so uh as where whereas
The Joint fiscal committee which is has
the responsibility of managing cash flow
uh for the for the state's expenditures
in the vium they have the expertise the
background and and the experience um uh
so that that certainly irked a lot of
Democrats and uh and the lawsuit
unfortunately uh failed uh but uh the
there's a lot of dissatisfaction with
among certain Republicans anyway with
regard to the um you know the the
executive orders being an overreach and
banning a freedom of assembly and
violating the Constitution so forth and
so on uh so looking at the scope and the
breadth of uh of the governor's
executive order uh uh process and
procedure and the the fundamental aspect
of how far it can go um is something
that I think we could appropriately and
constructively productively do uh in our
committee uh the other bills I think are
either unworkable or unwise or both um
and so I wouldn't support any of them
but I do think that uh that this is
something that that we have a
responsibility and enough experience on
the committee to to do something
productive with so that's my opening
Gambit
anyway yeah I I tend to to agree with
you in that we don't want to pass all
these bills what I was thinking about
when I saw saw them was that we would
take one and give it make a
simple a simple fix that we can agree on
and retain one to see how it works and
then let the others go go by the
wayside I mean the the question of
evacuations came up three times I think
one one law about evacuations is
plenty so uh yeah we
we should be looking at what the
governor has what we've given the
governor the authority to do and what
he's how he's how he's used it and taken
it because I personally think that the
fiscal committee probably should have
been
involved
but he didn't ask me
so
that Madam chair Please Speak oh ter
yeah I was wondering perhaps um if if
not now sooner we should maybe do a
straw pool just to see where everybody
stands on which Bill we want to use as a
vehicle to to set aside and go
forward well I had three suggestions of
yours and I'm okay with that so if
anybody has any uh I mean I I'm
I'm I wrote the Bill but I'm I'm not
necessarily married to it either way but
I definitely while while one side could
pass a bill I would not be happy doing
so I'd like to see um I'd like to see it
go forward with a message from both
parties that's fantastic I just want to
say
that isn't it nice when we
agree and actually I'm I'm I'm gonna
continue that because I initially
suggested uh starting with uh
433 because it's simple and
straightforward and we could add things
to it
however um I think youve convince me on
417 partly because it has the virtue of
dealing you know giving us the ability
to deal with individual emergency orders
and not having to have an All or Nothing
thing on on the state of emergency so I
think that's starting with 417 I'd be
fine
with I all around representative
Schultz yeah I think another reason why
and I please forgive me I don't think
anyone said this but I may have missed
it um I think one
another reason why I do think that that
rep royy bill is the best one is because
uh by focusing on the executive orders
there's no threat to whatever Federal
funding if I understand that whole
process correctly we can still
um we can still have that status it
doesn't make that status go away if I
understand it correctly and if we were
to just repeal New Hampshire's
participation in an
emergency status um forgive me if I'm
getting the language wrong that that
would mean we wouldn't have um the
protections we would need from uh the
federal government or you know help on
vaccines Etc that's too important of a
thing that focusing in on the executive
orders is the way we got a we finally
got a reply from the Department of
Safety on what F what the Federal
impacts would be if we ended the state
of emergency and I hope you all read
that because it was it was shocking how
much Federal money is is coming into the
state based on the fact that we're in a
state of
emergency unemployment and
um most unemployment was a big
part I agree I I mean I'm not sure of
what's really the case I've seen uh some
legal opinions which if I can get in
hard copy I'll for the committee that
said that that would be true if was just
a state state of emergency but given
there's a federal state of emergency
Stafford act uh would make us eligible
for all of that anyway but I am not
completely certain however I take uh
representative Schultz's uh point that
if we did it this way and could deal
with the emergency orders um you know
individually then we wouldn't that
wouldn't be a question at all which I'd
be happy
with one thing can't see us passing
anything that would be effective
immediately uh the word I've gotten is
that the governor is perfectly happy to
have a a bill that changes the emergency
authorization after this em state of
emergency is over and I think that's
reasonable you don't want to change the
rules however wrong they may have been
to start with in the middle of of an
emergency well that I mean that
certainly is something that that is
obvious to those of us who've been in
the legislature for a while and that is
that nothing is going to happen
immediately because we can't do it just
as the house uh we're not going to have
a session for a couple more weeks anyway
uh and then it would have Senate and so
forth so uh even presuming that the
Senate would buy into what the house had
done um it it is the governor you know
probably has a veto uh uh pen ready to
to strike it down but but nothing's
going to happen right away so and and
this this this whole effort to to attack
the whole structure of emergency orders
and and uh state of emergency and so
forth is clearly the daughter of the
pandemic situation we never had any
issues when the Cold River uh you know
tore out the center of alstate said and
the governor declared a special session
and state of emergency because that was
a local uh temporary issue that could be
addressed locally and and virtually all
the other emergencies that we have dealt
with in uh in our time in the
legislature have been either local or
Regional not Statewide or not long-term
this is a unique situation and because
it represents a disease that none of us
have ever experienced in the world world
has never experienced before uh even
though it's similar to the to the 1918
so-called Spanish Flu um which was a
unique disease as well uh and that was a
hundred years ago so this we're we're in
uncharted waters with regard to so many
aspects even to this day with
understanding all the aspects of covid
and seeing the new variants come out
practically every 10 minutes uh so uh
but but the the emergency order aspect
is something that we can
productively visit so I I'm totally in
favor of of retaining representative
Roy's Bill and uh and coming up be
unanimous
on well I think that the point of all
these bills coming in is that this is
the first extended emergency situation
we've had and so it tested all the
boundaries of the law that we passed
after 911 you know a one-week emergency
for a flood in alad or or a power an ice
storm across the you know half state
right doesn't corn of issues that you
get when you have almost a year and you
know and I remember well that the first
month or so there wasn't much outcry or
concern it's only when the emergency
started being renewed again and again
and more things got tied into it that
there was more concern and
unrest well and the lockdowns that
resulted from the emergency order began
to put uh small businesses out of
business that was clearly something that
was no fault to those peoples whatsoever
and I frankly thought that that sununu's
initial thing about essential and
non-essential was a quick way of getting
at uh that aspect to some degree but I
thought that relatively soon it should
have gone to uh uh permitting businesses
to reopen if they and their customers
could operate safely and whether
something was was essential or not was
not a
sufficiently uh you know precise and and
productive res resolution that it would
have been better I mean I got a friend
who operates a fireworks store I mean
clearly not something is essential but
could he operate it safely probably and
if he was then his business should not
have gone down the drain because uh it
wasn't an essential business and so I
think that that there are a lot of
things that we can improve if we work
together on this all right thank you
that's a good
point I'd like to just make one more
point if I could Madam chair the um when
we we look at
we've been looking at it from a a
perspective of you know one person has
you know too much
power is also the the angle that one
person it's a lawful lot of
responsibility and I don't want to
second guess the governor because I I I
don't know that I'd do anything
different if I knew that you know every
death was going to be hung on my head um
between 400 of us we've got broad
shoulders instead of one person having
to be responsible for every decision
life and death for such a long period of
time so I think it's worth looking at
both angles that it's not just about
reigning in power it's about
Distributing
responsibility Terry don't forget the
governor's got he's got commissioners of
safety commissioners of Health and Human
Services he's got a whole panoply the
whole AR Armada of state government is
at his disposal so I don't think he's
making these decisions all by himself
although it comes down to him ultimately
well yeah but the the issue is is that
it'll be on his head regardless of who
helps him with the decision at the end
of the day he's the one standing for
election and he'll be held accountable
represent
[Music]
comie thank you I'm listening to what
everybody what everyone is saying and I
guess the what I've been thinking is
what representative Schmid just said is
that we don't have
the
um expse or demand or not not demand we
don't have the expertise or the the
knowledge that state agencies have and
they're not um they're not really at our
disposal so how would you know how would
we as a state legisl how do you see this
happening as far as the state
legislature making a
decision well that's yeah the actually
the agencies do come and give us advice
in counsel uh you may not have noticed
but
the uh parade of Commissioners through
the finance committee is always
impressive we've had Commissioners here
talking about their departments and how
they want to run
um if they care believe me they'll
they'll let they they'll make their
opinion to
M but this would be presented to the
entire house right there wouldn't this
these this these decisions wouldn't be
handed down to a particular committee it
would be decided in the house right but
I believe that the Commissioners would
manage to make themselves known by
talking to their connections their uh to
to leadership to other Representatives
they know you know they all live in the
state I mean I had the commissioner of
administrative Services living in my
town for years when she wanted something
she made it very clear that she wanted
it yeah right I would think it would be
incumbent upon the governor to make his
case to us so that we can make the case
to our constituents so if he wants an
executive order he needs to bring his
experts before us and explain the
situation and if we buy in then we we
pass and explain it to our constituents
through this whole thing things have
been happening and people call me like
why did you do that and I'm like I have
no idea
got a comment yeah actually you beat me
to most of uh what I was going to say
there's no reason that we should assume
that the governor is going to have
access to information that's going to be
disallowed the legislature we should
have those same resources available to
us and the other thing I was going to
say is um maybe I'm saying what
everybody is already thinking and knows
but it seems that there's a lot of
agreement and that we need only to lay
this out methodically in in a few steps
like the initial declaration and then
you know the length of time that
declaration is enforc then when is it
time for involvement for the legislature
which branches of the
legislature uh and um really thrilled to
see that there really is a lot of
agreement here um I even want to say
that I
agree I don't recall which bill it was
but one of the bills provided for
essentially veto power for any of the
executive branch I mean executive
committee um I think that's doing the
same thing in a sense it's putting too
much power in one person's hand and
putting too much on one person's
shoulders and the last thing I'll say is
um uh you know for the the involvement
of the legislature
in extending and improving Governor's
initial emergency declaration uh it's it
would be unique to New Hampshire it's
it's done that way or supposed to be
done that way in Michigan
Wisconsin uh Pennsylvania we saw all
those legal battles play out during the
course of this past year where they have
those Provisions already in
Statue so I just think that if we took
it a piece at a
time and and we could plug in each piece
at a time and come to an agreement on
one piece we'll we'll put the right
thing
together
else have something something to
say something wrong this is going too
smoothly that's very funny
representative Pearson has his hand up
and he's been shaking his head a lot
soed to
speak we're just coming to watch what
real committee
doesc welcome taking a field trip we
have El we were supposed to be having
hearings from 1 to
3 and no one signed up No
One
S I mean and basically what was your
attendance like this morning um
moderately low we had the four bills
that finished up just before noon there
were only a couple of members of the
public um and one and one representative
of the Emergency
Management emergency management manager
from NASA came and spoke to us he had
some specific issues that he brought to
our
attention um so what I was going to say
is that uh while a number of these bills
address the
um require the mandatory or optional
evacuation I would
suggest keeping that completely separate
from what we're doing around uh state of
emergency emergency orders and all of
that um we got a separate bill it's mine
414 and we can debate that and people
can vote how they want on that but I
would suggest leaving that completely
out
of um you know whatever else we do
because I mean there is there's
legitimate disagreement on it I don't
think there's any need to to uh to Cloud
the uh dealing with the state of
emergency stuff with
that and Madam chair I'd like to suggest
a strategy if this
helps uh if you could let representative
Pearson Speak oh sorry yeah then we'll
get get back
to thank
you so for those of you on the committee
that are unaware I actually have a
master's degree in Emergency
Management how
convenient so um and I got it I was
involved in it before 911 so I've I was
in the very early days of the the
concept of of that being a
profession so one of the things
that we need to be very cautious
of
is losing sight of the
function of Rapid
action now there seems to be very
little disagreement here
on
what what fundamentally becomes a change
in status and I'll give you an
example in the fire service that that is
used all the time we we have a term
that's that's called under control it's
probably one of the most misquoted terms
the media uses um people like to
especially on social media like to
invent what that term actually means it
does not mean the fire is out it means
that the forward progress of the fire
has stopped and the situation in front
of us is manageable with the resources
and and Personnel that we have to
mitigate the
problem now under under a state of
emergency at some
point you go from the level of emergency
to the level of
management where that point
begins is solely dependent upon the
situation at
hand
and caution you know I looking at some
of these bills with the 21 days or the
days realistically historically anyway
the the overwhelming amount of of
declarations that have occurred have
been weather related
so those time frames really do fit you
know even with katr Katrina was probably
one of the better examples of of
something that went beyond 30 days and
that
was you know the the once in a in a
millennia type of type of
storm but the situation now has changed
in the sense
that where where we have spent decades
studying weather related emergencies and
things that come on in the framework of
that the the health emergency aspect has
has put this into a skew a little
bit so I I have certainly agreed
that at some
point there needs to be collaboration
there needs to be a check
there needs to be honestly maybe a step
back where where the legislative body
can look at this and say okay you know
the the the executive branch is you know
spending 15 18 hours a day working on
this and sometimes you get kind of lost
in amongst the trees here and certainly
having the legislative branch step back
you know and and say hey we're looking
at the whole Forest here and this is you
know this is what we see that's a good
thing
my what I just want to caution is us
overreaching this and losing the ability
for the executive branch to do what
constitutionally it is set up to
do which is to to act as the chief
executive of the state so you know I've
looked at the the the four bills that
were presented unfortunately um
representative Roy's bill I don't have
in print I'm kind of bouncing forward on
the general court website on that one
and and I think that there's definitely
some some good stuff here all four of
these bills by themselves are
problematic if they were just taking it
face value individually but but I think
realistically you know uh there's
there's an opportunity here to to look
at this not from the point of the
pandemic but from the point of hurricane
Roy or the white mous National Forest
being on fire
or any of the other interesting things
that seem to happen here so I I applaud
the effort I like what I've been hearing
so far and and I think that it's going
to take some work within our committee
to to hammer this out what I also want
to caution though is that
we we have four bills in front of us
that that are relatively similar I
suppose in stretch maybe with the
exception of
414 legie admin has a series of bills as
well that are in front of them we are
not tackling all of these together we're
not tackling these as a
Cojo committee type of effort and
Pearson I'd like to mention that uh five
members of legislative administration
had have come and joined us and they are
they're listening with great attention
okay that's that's that's fantastic
because my fear was that we would spend
a tremendous amount of time here
hammering through this only to
now have to rehash this or blend it with
what legie admin came up with with their
particular pieces of of legislation so I
I'm thankful that they're in the room
and and uh I look forward to you know
the the ideas that are going to be
brought forward
here I interested in your point that
there's a difference between the actual
emergency and then a continue situation
because I think that's kind of where we
are and that's where we need to be
careful of our language because of the
federal money they're trying to give
us can you expound on that sure I mean
you know real realistically at at the
point we're at now you know we have um
we have wellestablished testing
locations we have have well established
though slightly being tweaked on the Fly
um and expounded upon vaccine
distribution sites we have not modified
the concept of social distancing in
eight months we have not modified The
Mask mandate in at least eight months
probably realistically almost a year so
we are we are truly managing Co right
now we are not functioning in an
emergency fashion
that that took longer than I thought it
was going to mainly because the
information that we were getting from
fouchy was honestly be he was cont
contradicting himself every fifth day
and in a very fluid situation where
you're getting a lot of unknowns and a
lot of speculation and a lot of politics
all blended into one
thing we were not able to get a sense
of exactly what was going on quickly
for whatever reason and but that being
said the we are clearly Way Beyond the
point of the quote unquote emergency
aspect because we have a we we know what
it is we're where management functions
in the sense of the social distancing
and in the current
situation has shown to have effect and
you know we're just now we're just now
functioning through the process of
trying to get through
this that in and of itself is where I
think the core argument here is in the
sense
that what is what is a logical point in
time to say okay look we're really just
managing this emergency now we're not
it's not under under a an outof control
sense or or a sense of of too many
unknown variables so in and I think
clearly the legislature as a whole not
just the house the legislature as a
whole really does have a heavy
responsibility in making sure that not
only there's not an overreach of the
executive branch but in the but also in
the sense of the management function of
said problem is also
being done in in a proper way and
certainly you know we're never going to
have you know 424 us that are in loost
step on something for the most part
but you know I multiple calls with the
governor over this time period when I
was working with the National Guard on
things that needed to be tweaked and
problems that we had and and you know
but again that wasn't really that really
wasn't an emergency aspect of it it
really truly just was a management of
the
problem so bar and Katrina weather
related events have really never
exceeded 30 days with with us even the
ice storm was not stretched that long
so so I think that I we can easily agree
on a on a time frame that that is
prudent it to the 90 90th percentile and
then you know Institute the necessary
oversight
and
necessary or the ability to offer our
opinion if you will um into the process
you know once that once that initial
time period has
expired if I made any sense at all to
you guys I have no idea what you just
said right thank you representative
Schulz
then thank you very much Madam chair
okay here's my suggestion maybe
hopefully this is helpful um in
reviewing the bill and in listening to
all the testimony that I heard today I
think that
well one we can definitely start by
reviewing the bill line by line and do
informal straw polls on those and see
where we disagree but if whether we do
it before or after we could look at what
are the main points that the framework
of it should address and I'm going to
suggest just separate from Bill language
what those pieces of framework from my
point of view I think are and I think
this covers it I hope so the first
biggest piece of framework would be that
we want to make sure New Hampshire
statute sort of divorces the handling of
a declaration of emergency in in the
official Federal sense the state has to
declare one or the governor has to
declare one divorce that process from
what executive
orders how that process works uh even
though they're triggered by the
emergency declaration so that we can
address the executive orders without
harming a declaration of emergency so
that would be one the second would be uh
then to what degree and at what point do
the executive orders then involve the
House and Senate and three would be and
this is very parallel to what degree and
at what point does either the fiscal
committee and or Jael car uh interface
with our um you know play a role with
executive orders I think those are the
three main big
points from my observation if there are
more that's fine but going through
417 line by line might it's not that
long I think it's only roughly about 20
lines and some of them are just you know
basic
language does that help yes thank
you wants to say something well just for
the sake of saying it I'm bring some
ants to the picnic I'm not on board for
any of this um I'll listen but this is a
lot like uh my second wife you're never
going to hear it it's not going to
happen all of this commotion has
happened once in the republic since the
revolution this is like the United
Nations we're talking about something
that's never really going to come to
fruition if you want something I mean
after all we can resend the that the uh
state of emergency that declaration that
exists I might go for 2third of the
Senate to have a quick Nimble body he
gets out of control two-thirds of the
Senate uh shuts him down you can't get
two-thirds of the house probably uh just
physically uh and that's about but I'll
listen to the sh I'll listen to the
commotion and throw a few Stones now and
then but uh it why what are we doing
thanks okay thought that's good
point has a comment I think
representative Pearson brought a really
good uh I way to think about it to the
table and I have to disagree uh with
representative scitec because um you
know it it can happen it's actually
happening right here in this
committee and we're not talking about
right now ending the emergency order
what we're just talking about is is at
what point do we begin to manage it so
you're you're right I agree with you
actually 100% on on a chunk of what you
said that uh no this isn't going to
happen if we're talking about ending an
emergency order especially now but but
the way we manage
it after the initial declaration is I
think what the key point is
here thank
you anyone else have something to say
say repr Hills um my I guess my only
comment
um I've been kind of keeping it an eye
on the effective dates of the bills that
we have over at
Legette and and as a practical matter
the bills that we see and I'm assuming
the ones that you
have would require the governor's
signature to to go into
effect and I don't see that happening um
at least on the bills we're talking
about so I I think we do have to
separate this emergency versus future
emergencies um and that's where the
defining line should be um because I
think I think if we need to work on
anything first it's it's these effective
dates um so that nothing really happens
till after you know I think that it's
it's easy enough to say you know
effective 30 days after the termination
of the of the current state of
emergency uh some of these say January
2022 which certainly hope is after the
effect right but yeah but I we're
not we're not looking at to say we want
to examine the current state of
emergency we want to say in if a future
Governor were to declare state of
emergency
over whatever Spanish flu or whatever or
that's what we should be look
considering
because
um we could we could spend all day
second guessing the
governor chair point of order could you
please introduce us to the new to the
members who joined because I can't I
don't know them and I very good point
could the members of legislative
Administration introduce yourselves sure
is this this microphone is working well
yes so um here here in the room is uh I
am the chairman uh Greg Hill of legi
admin ranking member is
here Jan Janet
wall Vice chair of legi admin is here
Bob
Green clerk is here Vanessa
Sheen and uh our honored member is uh
Matt Simon is also here I noticed you
brought your whole leadership team
and
okay
um there were some discussions held with
the governor actually this
summer around this and uh you know as
you would expect he was strongly opposed
to any changes that would impact the
current state of emergency
however he did say he was certainly open
to uh going along with uh you know some
changes to you know this 445 or other uh
statutes related to the emergency power
so it's not like he was uh completely
opposed to any of this no if I recall he
actually asked us please take it away he
said he'd be happy to but currently he
couldn't okay that makes
sense
who's next any any comments from
the I just feel like we're doing with
two separate things in the story I
think kind of touched on it there are
emergency orders that have to deal with
weather and they're very different in
kind from the present one that we find
ourselves in which have to do with
health related issues and so I think I'm
trying to kind of divide these things is
it's it's hard come up with an approach
that encapsulates both of those things
and I'm almost wondering if we need to
propose something that that addresses
those two things in a different way well
one point may be that a 30-day period is
long enough for almost any weather
related incident and it's only
a a health related thing probably that
could go on
longer
I was basically uh gonna say that but
also regarding what representative
Pearson said you know the uh 417 as it's
written would let the governor declare
the state of emergency and it extends it
from 21 to 30 days uh but then it would
kick in the provisions um that would get
the legislature involved in approving uh
you know anything further and I think
that would split you know the uh weather
related and that sort of thing could be
handled in the way it has been because
certainly within 30 days the case and
anything that's going to drag on longer
it is I think very important for the
legislature to take up its uh
responsibility to get involved and this
would allow
[Music]
that y
sorry
the um yeah there there's potentially
one or two one or two scenarios that I
can I can think of historically in New
Hampshire that would would go a little
bit beyond the 30 days but but I assure
you in those scenarios there would be no
disagreement as to extension so I I
don't really think that that puts us at
a um at a risk of a political bottleneck
certainly so the only other one we had
was
um Governor
hasson's opioid right yes but she didn't
do much else except declare the state of
emergency and let it expire it was she
was not an activist governor on that
that
emergency yeah she Governor Hassen
declared the opioid crisis of emergency
and that that was the extent of her
involvement as far as I could
tell anyone else that's a
the the other the other question I would
like to put on the table is somewhere
along the line there needs to
be some recognition of the ability of
the governor to it um to change in some
minor or major fashion his executive
order or his emergency order and start a
new one um so so how effective is that
day initial initial period if if all he
needs to do is then change it in some
fashion to to Jin up another 21 days um
I'm not sure how that's going to be
addressed as well that's a good question
that wouldn't under 47 that that
wouldn't be possible he'd have to um
he'd have to bring each each one before
the house and if we amend it the Senate
um so any new order he
did um has to come in other words 417
doesn't doesn't judge his decision to
make a state of emergency it judges his
executive orders so he could extend the
state of emergency as much as he wants
he just can't do anything with it unless
we approve it beyond that 30-day
[Music]
period uh thank you madam chair um I
guess I just I I'm in agreement with um
with retaining one of the bills 417 is
fine uh you know to work at UH and talk
further in the future one of the things
that I thought of is uh we've talked
exclusively of either health related or
weather related uh emergencies and we we
live in a part of the country where we
don't seem to have earthquakes or forest
fires to the extent they do other areas
so at least we at least at this time we
haven't um the other thing that we
always have a a possibility of and and
what I thought of during the talk about
evacuation orders is a catastrophic
event at the seab brook uh Nuclear
Station and that could turn in certainly
to a state of emergency Andor evacuation
orders um in in that in that part of the
state at least so and I don't know you
know I guess depending on the extent
whether it would last more than 30 days
but um just something else to consider
while we're looking at the overall
structure of the
bill okay represent
Pearson I'm glad you mentioned cab Brook
because in another lifetime I was
involved in the nuclear
business let let me assure you there are
very few things that exist right now
that terrify people more than the
concept of sebr having a
problem um from a compliance
standpoint I can't think of any other
thing in the state that would render
more voluntary compliance than an
incident at Seabrook I personally
was
lived I think I'm I was six miles dead
west of 3 Mile Island when that happened
so my family has a little bit of
experience when it comes to dealing with
problems at nuclear power
plants the concept one of the things
that I have I have concerns about when
it comes
to this idea of of 414 and the idea of
involuntary you know uh the ability to
choose not to
evacuate and I'm sure that
representative lanzera representative
goalie representative O'Brien will
certainly easily back me up on this I
have physically removed moved people out
of structures that were on
fire that did not want to leave those
structures okay so I can I can tell you
that the the general overall idea that
people would just generally do the smart
and right thing shockingly does not
always hold true
okay the fact that someone would be
reluctant to to leave a building that
was clearly on fire is not
a rational person has a really hard time
relating to that okay but we've done it
multip the M or fire department has done
it so many times it's not countable
really truly
so you
know the the concept of of the the
removal at the end of the gun
scenario there is really truly no way
and we saw this in Katrina there is
there is truly no way to put in a
provision to allow someone to to void
themselves of their rights to
assistance um you know we we don't I
can't contemplate a procedure for that I
can't contemplate a way that the
Emergency Services would be able to know
who was and wasn't who could verify what
would be the ability for someone to
change their mind I mean that that
exists under under a DNR a do not
resuscitate order has the ability to to
be changed and rescinded almost
instantly so I I just
couldn't the this the whole concept of
this is just so massively
problematic and that completely ignores
the fact that folks that are in the
emergency services business as a general
rule do not look at folks that are in a
dire situation and keep
walking that is against the nature of
people that are in that profession it is
not something that you could train into
those
people and it makes the entire concept
of this honestly impossible it it truly
does and I I just want to I want to
reiterate that to the folks that are
that are not necessarily familiar with
the Emergency
Services industry but
um I get the theory I suppose you have
the right to die in a hurricane if you
want
but to to tie in what First Responders
would would have to do with that is is
not something that can be practically
done so thank you okay pres
shels thank you um I will say I don't
know if I understand everything
representative peon has said just to be
honest about that I will say though if
part of what we're doing here is trying
to determine if this is
even uh needed in the future
unfortunately uh or fortunately since we
are a global uh Community now the
chances that we're going to have another
pandemic are significantly higher than
they were a hundred years ago and we
have been lucky and fortunate to have
dodged this kind of a
bullet um sooner to be honest with you
so
unfortunately I believe we'll have uh
few less than a hundred years till we
get to the next pandemic
unfortunately and if that's the only
thing holding us
back um because that's
indeterminable uh I think it's helpful
to do a bill and then I just wanted to
see no one said anything in response to
my suggestion of how we could then
structure the discussion on any specific
bill but
um yeah I do think going line by line at
the bill to start is good and then
looking at what is our framework then I
made that suggestion whether you do my
suggestion or someone's else I think it
would be helpful then to be more
concrete than will we ever need this
again let's just assume we
will Madam chair can we get a
subcommittee maybe what's that have you
entertained theide of a subcommittee to
kind of narrow this down uh yes I had
originally thought of a subcommittee but
right now um we're Limited in the number
of times we can meet um I suspect that
after crossover we will have more time
available and that's why I want to
retain one of these bills to work out
more of the details
representative Shu and then algro then
gold thank you madam chair um yes I I um
was actually going to suggest that
perhaps uh we should look at meeting as
a committee of the whole on this issue
it's a pretty big issue with a lot of
different ideas so I offer that but what
I was going to say is um talking about
long-term emergencies and as someone who
had has survived three major earthquakes
in Southern
California I can tell you all that I had
looked into the possibilities of
earthquakes in New Hampshire they don't
happen often but with the granite base
to our geology I have heard that if we
have a major earthquake it would be
catastrophic and I can tell you
firsthand the aftermath of a major
earthquake
leads you in several different
directions the immediate response is
taking care of people who are injured or
killed but then the next response is
those who are survivors are left with
either no infrastructure roads are
destroyed your access to food water and
electricity is
destroyed um just many many aspects that
come up and the long-term going going
forward is not going to be solvable
within 30 days I can tell you that so I
think looking at this particular thing
going forward we do need to consider the
long-term aspects thank
you uh yes I I think we keep still keep
on muddling the different subjects like
evacuation and um I wasn't going to
address evacuation even though I had it
in my notes but uh representative
Pearson compulsory versus non-compulsory
evacuation it's not only not improbable
and undoable but it works and I speak as
someone who's lived through Hurricane
Katrina and countless evacuation orders
compulsory and
non-compulsory people make their own
decision and I have to agree with you
that um a um an emergency worker will
tend to run towards the danger even if
they're not uh required to but that's
true of citizens as
well um so again i' I've lived through
countless ordered
evacuations and in fact part of the core
problem that we're facing
today are those very evacuation orders
those those very emergency declaration
orders because what happens is people
become immune to them you know in in
Louisiana Texas Florida you get
countless screeching orders to evacuate
and what happens is people just say ah
the last 18 of them were just it was
ridiculous um and so there are times
when people should evacuate and they
don't but the bottom line is is
people make their own decision uh out of
the goodness knows how many evacuation
order as I was present for in that part
of the country we evacuated
twice I'm glad that we did but we
assessed it on our own as did our
friends and neighbors we made the
decision on our own and we actually
wound up better for doing what we did
and as has been pointed out earlier in
the day regardless of what an emergency
worker or a regular citizen would do
whether they would run towards or away
from the danger even if they're not
required to regardless of that it's you
know once the governor says there's an
emergency and everybody knows is
emergency it's been declared at that
very same time the governor declares
whether evacuation is compulsory or
recommended so everyone who knows
there's an emergency knows the
circumstances of evacuation
order and then that person's decision to
evacuate it doesn't take signing a paper
like was thrown out earlier in the day
how do we get people to acknowledge that
they're going to uh not evacuate do we
get them to sign a paper no their
presence in their
domicile is their answer to the world
I'm still here I've decided not to
evacuate I understand that you don't
have to come back and save me thank you
if you will but I understand you do not
have to so just leave me alone and let
me tend to my own amilies and my safety
and the protection of our property but
we keep muddling these different
subjects we really need to focus nothing
we've talked about today none of these
bills curtail the governor's ability to
declare an emergency I don't I don't
think there's any inkling of that in any
of these bills I could be
mistaken so piece number one is in place
the governor gets to declare an
emergency then it just becomes an issue
of after X number of days how do we
manage it and if we take that
methodically uh maybe using the uh some
of the ideas that representative Schulz
suggested if we take that methodically
then we could move forward step by step
and putting together some some rational
legislation thank you
goie thank you madam
chair Madam chair uh this is a question
I guess if we are in agreement that
something is going to be retained um the
discussion going on here some of it
starting to sound more like a debate
that should be taking place during an
exec session um if this is a true work
session we should have a bill or two in
front of us and work on it line by line
um but if we're really looking at
entertaining I I think the best thing to
do is to figure out which Bill we want
to retain and which bills we want to
work on um so that work can be
accomplished because I and honest all
honesty don't think this is really a
work session this is just more or less
debating the
bills just looking for a little
Direction on this okay well in that case
how about saying that we will take house
build
417 and use that as something
to come forward
with language for this
year whether or not probably not perfect
but expressing some of the ideas we've
been
developing and
retain
separately House Bill 414 on evacuations
as I agree with black it's a totally
different subject we don't need to to
conflate that with the uh the
emergencies it's a totally separate
issue and take any reference to
evacuations out of any of the others
[Music]
and deal separately probably rain and I
think um 275 is broader than 433 so
that' be a better one to retain it's
more things would be gerin to
it any uh
[Music]
does that make sense any violent
objections to
that I'm just a little confused um so
you want to retain 275 to work on what
if you want to do
47 I want to develop some amendments to
417 that will incorporate the ideas
we've discussed and semi agreed on um
it's got the 30
days I want to add the Senate want to
add the Senate and
um specifically adding the Senate and
some of the other comments about
uh oversight on executive
orders as representative Schmidt said
that's something that's in our perview
and that's kind of mentioned in 417 so I
I would want to go home and and read
this very carefully and think about
where we need to
um where we would want to make changes
because it's got a lot of what we've
been talking about that the governor
declares the emergency for 30
days
and then the legislature has as the
um oversight of the executive
orders question of the
chair yes uh Madam chair if um if we
work on
417 do we have until if I'm looking at
the rules correctly the deadlines do we
have up until March
18th to decide that perhaps we don't
have it ready yet and we still um put
forward a retain motion up until that
date uh up until the speaker was saying
this morning at the chair's meeting that
he's
contemplating changing some of the
deadlines because he wants to minimize
the number of sessions we
have so this will undoubtedly be exact
at the last possible
moment okay thank
you madam share yes goie uh just a quick
question and
um would it not be better to give these
a thorough review by retaining
uh with the understanding uh in the
discussion we had earlier that none of
this of the decisions we make now
are looking to make changes to the
current state of emergency so there is
no need to act on
something right now that we can give
this a thorough vetting that it needs as
a
committee uh possibly you may be right
but on the other hand we don't know that
in the middle of May the White Mountain
National Forest is and going to burst
into
flames which is one of the scenarios
that representative Pearson's brought up
as being a major non-weather related
emergency that would need to might last
more than 30 days um so I I would like
to at least try to come up with
something on it um we can always retain
it at the last minute yeah that was my
point yes yeah we we'll we'll work on it
if we can't agree that it's got most of
what we want to as a framework for
handling
longterm emergencies then we can retain
it then but I would kind of like to try
to come up with
something just wanted to uh answer kind
of a question from representative
Schultz about her framework um I I think
it off hand it looks good I haven't said
anything because uh I'd need to go
through the bill and think about it some
more to to to decide if those are the
right things if it needs to be anything
else which I couldn't do while listening
to everything else but U you know thanks
for at least starting
that Madam chair I appreciate that sorry
I'd be happy to be a repository for um
amendments so if everyone wants to take
their time and read this and send and
then we next week inene to discuss this
we can go over each possible Amendment
and vote it up or down that's a very
good idea represent Pearson
muted unmute Steve I was
trying I'm trying to remember what the
heck I was gonna
say okay got it this has to do with well
we I guess I'll address this to the the
chair of legie admin um what just
left all right we got any backups in the
room doesn't look like
it okay because we didn't discuss what
any of their bills look like and if and
how they fit into the framework of our
bills yes very true we got to narrow it
down first if we can get one good one
and they can come up with one and maybe
we
can right now we got way too many things
floating
around
okay
represent um my hand was up Peter
Schmidt yours
wasn't um anyway sorry big deal then go
ahead and
talk Jesus some kind of a game no so if
I remember correctly during your
testimony on your bill representative
Roy um you mentioned there were a few
states that correct me if I'm wrong but
I think you mentioned some States that
had actually gone to the effort of
introducing new rules or laws pertaining
to the executive power Visa the
legislature do you remember which states
those were and because it might be
helpful for us to just on our own look
some of that up um that was not me and
it was not my bill um it wasn't of the
other ones I think I totally made that
up sorry that's okay I believe the
states mentioned were Michigan and
wiscons
but in Pennsylvania
yes but this this may be long
existing thank
you all right well I'm noticing a lack
of enthusiasm bubbling up um does anyone
else have something something to
add I just was going to say that one of
the bills that ledge Administration has
is uh House Bill
187 which deals primarily with the
Commissioner of Health and Human
Services and it's got several aspects of
it that are very problematical I believe
but that's one that I have taken a look
at I don't I don't know the other ones
and I haven't looked at them
representative Schmid are in lock House
Bill 187 passed the house last week and
is was sent to Edna we will be having a
session on it uh
possibly the 15th maybe
later we will into all of those all of
those issues at that
time got my knife
sharpened excellent excellent and your
and your and your
pen okay anyone else have important
issues Madame chairman can I interject
briefly I just want to mention that I
sent around a a memo with all the bills
that went to um legislative
Administration and Edna also Health and
Human Services where 187 started and um
criminal justice and Judiciary I believe
also had some state of emergency bills
so I summarize very briefly but
certainly there's a a single document
that you all have that that lists all
the state of emergency bills and and um
just a brief summary of each one
excellent as well as the history on of
the current state of emergency law which
I hope was helpful also thank you so
going forward we will all read these
bills again and think about them submit
suggested language changes to House Bill
417 to representative
Roy
and not worry about the other other oh
house bill 414 the
evacuations
uh I we
can try and execute or we can retain it
I think maybe retention might be better
it's not a an urgent bill I don't
think okay so we will uh retain 414 and
probably 275 and itl 433 so I think
that's
the narrowest of the bills and Madam
chair yes representative
goalie um I think when we exec 414 that
should be on the merits of itself
whether do you feel that
um you're absolutely
correct we should not because I can't I
can't agree to retaining it I just don't
agree with that policy
change policy
change 414 yes fine we
it we consider what it on its merits
thank
you I got the impression from what you
were saying Madam chair that uh that we
could kind of to some degree sit on one
on one or two of the these bills before
we have to make the for final decision
as to whether we're going to retain or
whatever we do have a couple of weeks
representative Schmidt but I think want
to focus our attention on
4117 because that seems to be the the
closest to what Mo most most of us
want I agree if you have a section that
you think you have better language for
we we let's send it to representative uh
Roy and we'll consider how to arrange
those
suggestions very good okay and we are
meeting again
Thursday
see 10
o'clock uh I think it's
10:30 okay
[Music]
10:30 all right any
uh any other comments questions
suggestions whoever arranged the uh the
Confluence of meeting with alleged
Administration uh was on the ball so
thanks for that he I was very nice of
them to show
up right thank you all and and thank
Miss Marling for some excellent research
because that'll save us a lot of digging
out on our
own you just to confirm you're saying
the next time we're going to meet is
going to be March 8th no the 4th we're
meeting March 4th which is Thursday at
10:30 we are going to exact the weather
modification statute and whatever else
we can get to if we have some different
language suggested for 4177 we could
certainly discuss it
then Madam
chair I'm sorry recognize me represent
Shu yes thank you yes I just wanted to
thank you for uh soliciting the input
Homeland Security uh I thought that
informed our discussions today great
you're welcome we lots of people have
been asking about that and it's really
nice to get a definitive answer for a
change yes rather than trading
ignorances all right right very good
thank you all and I'll see you
Thursday